bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour cette
journée de live une journée très
importante pour deux candidats marine le
pen d'un côté eric zemmour de l'autre
eric zemmour qui tient en ce moment son
meeting à lille marine le pen qui va le
tenir un peu plus tard dans un peu moins
d'une heure
arras nous sommes avec albane boc albane
wauquiez sur place à reims on va aller
la rejoindre albane vous être à reims
depuis le début de la journée pour ce
meeting qui est trés important pour
pour marine le pen est-ce que vous
pouvez nous décrire un peu l'ambiance ce
qui sait ce que vous avez vu depuis vous
êtes arrivés sur place
oui tout à fait l'instant nous sommes en
direct au parc des expositions à reims
où vous le voyez derrière moi c'est près
de 3000 militants et rennes qui sont
venus pour soutenir marine le pen
aujourd'hui alors vous les voyez sans
doute peut-être également demandé
drapeau français bleu blanc rouge et des
drapeaux blancs ornés du m marine le pen
et il continue encore d'arriver pour
certains mais la plupart sont là on les
a vus cet après midi ils ont crié des
slogans on est chez nous on les a
entendus la salle s'est un peu calmée là
puisqu'on est entre deux ils attendent
les prises de parole à 17 heures mais
l'après midi a commencé avec la prise de
parole de laurent jacot belli et
philippe ballard est lui à rennes puis
ensuite sont succédé les tables rondes
autour de thématiques de la campagne
présidentielle alors l'immigration la
famille l'école l'écologie la question
de l'énergie et bien sûr la question du
pouvoir d'achat thème central de cette
campagne présidentielle désormais les
militants attendent de la prochaine
prise de parole à 17 heures
avec charles sa part charles sapin qui
suit marine le pen au quotidien pour le
figaro je vous laisse un peu avoir la
main avec lui pour discuter de nuit avec
lui sur les enjeux finalement de ce
meeting
c'est un travail bonjour
quelle est la stratégie de marine le pen
dans cette grande convention
présidentielle
alors là la stratégie de marine le pen a
les doubles déjà c'est son premier grand
meeting de campagne présidentielle c'est
un moment qui était très attendu qui a
été reportée à cause du coc vide à cause
aussi de questions d'organisation c'est
un moment qui était très attendu pour
ses militants et du coup son objectif là
aujourd'hui cet après midi c'est déjà de
répondre à son principal rival le rival
nationaliste qui est eric zemmour
répondre par les images par la
mobilisation par la ferveur qu'elle va
essayer de relever en fait dans cette
salle de sympathisants adhérents et son
objectif aussi là ça sera plus dans le
discours dans ses mots c'est de
ressusciter son duel avec emmanuel
macron elle va commencer son discours
par un long bilan du chef de l'état où
elle va tirer évidemment un boulet rouge
c'est une façon pour elle de s'élever au
niveau du chef de l'état et de
recrédibiliser un peu ce le scénario du
second tour de 2017 en disant voilà
finalement je suis la première opposante
à emmanuel macron c'est moi qui
logiquement devrait me retrouver au
second tour cette fois ci encore passons
de prendre de la hauteur et de
d'asphyxier le sait ses autres
adversaires vous l'avez dit cet
après-midi marine le pen un peu face à
eric zemmour qui tient également son
meeting à lille quelle est sa stratégie
pour se positionner face à lui alors sa
stratégie particulièrement face à eric
zemmour c'est de jouer la différence il
ya enfin la différence quoi se
différencier par rapport à lui elle
décrit eric zemmour au long des
entretiens des interviews sur les
plateaux télé et puis et puis là elle a
échangé un peu avec pas mal de
journalistes sujets communs comme un
candidat de plateaux télé un parisien
loin des français qui manie des concepts
un peu floue un peu théorique et elle
elle se dépeint au contraire comme une
candidate de terrain très proche des
français c'est pour ça tout à l'heure on
a assisté au départ d'une quinzaine de
bus qui va partir en région dans des
petites villes rurales à la rencontre
des français voilà c'est vraiment elle
surjoue ce côté je suis la candidate du
terrain proche des français alors qu'ils
aient pour lui sur les plateaux télé et
finalement un peu éloigné des gens je
suis la candidate des programmes de
propositions pragmatiques alors que lui
ce concept flou et puis il ya aussi le
troisième dimension c'est que c'est on
le voit notamment ces derniers jours
dans un entretien qu'elle a donnée au
figaro elle diabolise son adversaire
elle dit voilà eric zemmour on voit
autour d'eric zemmour tout un tas de
chapelles qu'on a connu il ya des
dizaines d'années au front national avec
des catholiques intégristes
des païens et des nazis bon voilà en
fait elle se sert
d'une technique de descrimination de
diabolisation qu'on lui a beaucoup
opposés notamment la gauche que le a
beaucoup opposé en fait elle se sert de
la même technique qu'on lui a opposé
pendant des années mais contre eric
zemmour contre ce rival nationaliste
quelles sont ses soutiens notables
présent aujourd'hui
là il ya tout le monde c'est vraiment la
grande messe de début de campagne
présidentielle donc vous avez des euro
députés comme jean la capelle vous avez
son conseiller spécial philippe olivier
vous avez des députés comme sébastien
chenu vous avez évidemment le président
du rassemblement national jordan barbe
et là vous avez des conseillers
régionaux vins il ya à peu près tout le
monde en revanche il ya quelques absents
et des absents qui sont très remarquée
évidemment ceux qui ont franchi le
rubicon qui sont partis chez eric
zemmour je pense aux eurodéputés jérôme
rivière gilbert collard notamment et
puis vous avez aussi des absents c'est à
dire des gens qui sont pas encore en
franchit le rubicon mais qui existent
géré on sait qu'ils sont indécis entre
les deux candidatures de marine le pen
et d'eric zemmour il ya le sénateur
stéphane ravier qui n'est pas là et il y
à l'euro débute et nicolas bay s'est
fait excuser pour cause de covin mais on
connaît ses doutes voilà sur le
positionnement il ya une autre absence
qui ont beaucoup de militants parlent en
ce moment c'est marion maréchal ce n'est
pas étonnant a jamais pris part à un
événement un meeting dur du
rassemblement national depuis la
dernière présidentielle depuis 20 depuis
les dernières législatives depuis 2017
mais
pareil son hésitation
ces confidences notamment dans le figaro
font que beaucoup de gens on parle
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup charles pour
ces informations
merci à charles d'être sur place
j'accueille mon invité en plateau
bonjour bonjour frédérick michaud merci
d'être avec nous aujourd'hui je vous
remercie pour votre invitation on va
parler un peu aujourd'hui de tout ce que
ça représente ce duel aujourd'hui entre
eric zemmour d'un côté marine le pen de
l'autre comment elle a essayé comment
elle essaye de ceux de se sortir un peu
de la situation dans laquelle l'ami eric
zemmour c'est tendance déjà est-ce qu'on
va parler un peu du côté sondages de
marine le pen comment évolue sa
candidature comment est-elle reçu eh
bien écoutez sa candidature quand on
regarde les intentions de vote
évidemment sur la longue durée ça a été
bien rappelé par par vos journalistes
sur le terrain il ya quand même un
décrochage qui a eu lieu lors des
élections régionales de juin dernier
jusqu alors on avait le sentiment d'un
duel inéluctable entre le chef de l'état
et marine le pen elle était assurée de
figurer au second tour avec un score qui
variait entre 25 26% des intentions de
vote au premier tour les élections
régionales ont été un premier un premier
avertissement pour pour elle dans les
sondages d'intentions de vote mais c'est
surtout l'émergence la percée d'eric
zemmour qui qui lui a porté un coup très
rude puisque son score dans les
intentions de vote a été très largement
diminuée elle est aujourd'hui sous la
barre des 20% à hauteur de 2 18% dans
notre de 17% dans notre dernière mesure
juste juste devant valérie pécresse d'un
point 16% et elle devance de trois
points eric zemmour trois points d'écart
mi janvier il y avait entre marine le
pen et eric zemmour il y avait sept
points d'écart donc eric zemmour petit à
petit gagne du terrain et aujourd'hui on
a trois candidats dans la marge d'erreur
qui sont tous statistiquement en tout
cas en mesure d'être qualifié de se
qualifier d'être présent pour le second
tour donc là il ya vraiment un élément
très très fort d'atr pour ce début de
campagne de marine le pen un des enjeux
aujourd'hui c'est de se démarquer
précisément d'eric zemmour pour tenter
de de regagner de de progresser dans
l'opinion et puis de pouvoir regagner
cette assurance de figurer au second
tour est ce que ça veut dire justement
que ces trois candidats et règlements
valérie pécresse le pen à l'instant t on
vous avait parlé de marge d'erreur pour
qu'on rappelle bien ce que c'est ça veut
dire que on ne sait pas exactement quand
c'est pas déjà on ne pourrait pas savoir
exactement dans tous les cas mais ça
les cartes combinant rabattus oui ça
signifie que statistiquement nous ne
sommes pas en mesure d'identifier
l'identité du candidat qui sera opposée
qui serait opposé emmanuel macron
emmanuel macron lui aujourd'hui est en
tête des intentions de vote avec un
score de 24 % dont vous voyez
7 7 points d'écart par rapport par
rapport à marine le pen et là pour le
coup c'est un écart qui est important
qui est au delà des martyrs eur/nok lui
aujourd'hui alors même qu'il n'est pas
candidat peut-être que ça changera mais
aujourd'hui il serait assurée d'être
présent au second tour en revanche nous
ne sommes pas en mesure à date de dire
qu'ils fassent à qui il serait opposé ça
peut parfaitement être eric zemmour ça
peut être marine le pen et ça peut être
valérie pécresse est une vraie un
décision de la part de l'électorat de
droite ou des droites cantat au candidat
qui devra affronter emmanuel macron
comment ont évolué les intentions de
vote en faveur d'eric zemmour depuis sa
candidature en septembre il a fait une
percée puis après ils en appel et il se
stabilise depuis oui il a fait une
percée ensuite il s'est stabilisé entre
au plus bas
11 % dans les sondages plus haut qui
était son niveau actuel
14% donc au cours du mois de janvier il
ya une petite progression qui n'a rien à
voir avec la dynamique qui a été
enregistré à l'automne qui est une
dynamique atypique et je dirais même
unique dans l'histoire des sondages sous
la vème république en tout cas dans les
campagnes présidentielles
voilà là depuis et depuis le mois de
janvier avec les différents aliments
qu'on plutôt des effets symbolique des
effets électoraux former tout cas ça
s'est un peu d'un petit effet je
parlerai pas dynamique parce que ce
serait abusif mais voilà il en tout cas
elle n'a pas décroché comme certains le
prédisaient et puis il revient petit à
petit talonné valérie pécresse et marine
le pen ces ralliements vous l'avez dit
beaucoup on parle pas de gilbert collard
qui est qui qui qui a rejoint et xénon
il n'y a pas si longtemps ça ne porte
pas de temps prévu ni ce que ça selon
vous pour l'instant mais en fait on a
bien vu la stratégie de l'équipe de
campagne d'eric zemmour qui consiste à
feuilletonner ces différents aliments
puisqu'il y en a un qui est annoncé
chaque week-end depuis le début du mois
de janvier et ses différents aliments
n'ont pas eu un effet comme je le disais
très important dans les intentions de
vote le premier le ralliement de
guillaume pelletier n'a absolument aucun
effet la courbe d'intentions de vote
d'eric zemmour avant et après l annonce
du ralliement de guillaume pelletier est
resté parfaitement stable celle de
gilbert collard a eu un petit peu plus
d'effet mais un effet à la fois
éphémère et puis relativement limités et
un retour à la normale ensuite le
week-end dernier l'évocation du d'un
possible ralliement de marion
maréchal-le pen a eu peut-être un effet
un petit peu plus important d'abord
parce que c'est une figure qui est plus
plus connus qu'à plus de surface mais
dette médiatique et politique que les
que les ralliements précédent et puis
aussi parce qu'on a cet effet cumulatif
ins et troisième le troisième week-end
d'affilée où on annonce des ralliements
et donc sa porte dans l'opinion publique
mais il ya un phénomène qui est très qui
est très paradoxal on a la
reconnaissance que ces différents
aliments au plan symbolique sont
importants eric zemmour c'est le
candidat qui la semaine dernière a
marqué le plus de points d'après les
français donc stratégiquement on
reconnaît que c'est à son bénéfice mais
pourtant quand nous regardons les
intentions de vote nous mesurons
seulement des variations très légère
même un film donc voilà on à cette
situation un petit peu paradoxal l'un
des enjeux aujourd'hui pour marine le
pen c'est d'abord de limiter de mettre
un terme à cette hémorragie c'est ce à
quoi elle s'est employée toute la
semaine et puis surtout montrer qu'elle
est entourée qu'est ce qu'il y a une
équipe autour d'elle et que ces
ralliements sont simplement le fait de
de quelques ambitieux ou de quelques
personnalités
individuelles qui ont pu être déçus dans
leurs ambitions parce que charles sapin
le rappeler c'est le premier grand
meeting de marine le pen qui devait
avoir lieu plus tôt en janvier qui a été
reportée à cause du coc vide ce grand
meeting ça permet en général de créer
une dynamique et de lancer une campagne
voilà alors le grand meeting c'est
l'entrée en matière dans une campagne
électorale c'est un élément qui est
toujours décisif rappelez-vous le grand
meeting de nicolas sarkozy porte de
versailles en
2007 à l'époque on parlait du du du
sarkoshow pour dire à quel point c'était
un véritable spectacle ça crée un
sentiment de puissance et c'est lui a
permis d'enclencher une dynamique
électorale et de reprendre l'ascendant
sur ségolène royal le grand meeting de
françois hollande au bourget mon ennemi
c'est la finance tout le monde s'en
souvient là aussi ça permet d'imposer
une stature et donc de véritablement
lancer une campagne électorale c'est un
moment très important dans une campagne
électorale ça permet évidemment de
dévoiler son programme son projet
peut-être quelques mesures symboliques
mais c'est aussi très important en terme
d'image sur quoi ils arrivent à se
différencier avec eric zemmour justement
parce que on a l'impression que
aujourd'hui eric zemmour à lille
attendait 8016 7000 8000 participants
elles trois ou quatre mille c'est
pourtant pas si simple
c'est pas aussi pas mathématique en
disant qu'il est deux fois plus
populaire qu elle pour autant non et
puis alors il faut vraiment se méfier
des effets d'affluence dans l'est
meeting ce n'est pas un indicateur
absolument pas un indicateur positif du
vote on a vu les campagnes électorales
précédentes les candidats qui avaient
des salles pleines avec une vraie
ferveur avec beaucoup d'enthousiasmé
finalement tout seul s'est pas traduit
en gains électoraux et puis voilà c'est
tout ça est vraiment à prendre avec des
pincettes alors ça a un effet ça a un
effet médiatique
mais c'est pas un élément qui est
prédictive du vote elle a une image qui
s'est améliorée dans l'opinion publique
et qui s'est améliorée notamment par
contraste avec eric zemmour je dirais
que eric zemmour d'une certaine manière
à la remplacer en terme d'image sur sur
l'échiquier politique
lui aujourd'hui une image qui est
beaucoup plus dégradée que celle de
marine le pen alors les deux ont des
images qui sont mauvaises dans
l'ensemble de la de de l'opinion mais
l'image de marine le pen lcl s'est
adouci à la fois sur la longue durée par
cet effet de banalisation c'est la
fameuse c'est la fameuse politique de
dédiabolisation de normalisation de
l'image du front national ça a été
entamé il ya une dizaine d'années c'est
pas normal que ça produisent des des
résultats mais aussi vraiment par
comparaison avec l'image d'eric zemmour
qui paraît beaucoup plus dure beaucoup
plus radicale qu'elle elle va sans doute
aujourd'hui essayer de jouer à fond le
contre-pied pour pour vraiment démarqué
son image de celle d'eric zemmour
effectivement jean temps on voit sur les
images tournées en ce moment par daphné
caravaca avec albane doc qui suit ce
meeting on entend on est chez nous on
est chez nous il ya il ya un peu
d'ambiance ils commencent à arriver
albane je sais pas si vous entendez
j'ai l'impression qu'elle lit à côté
mais c'est vraiment on récupérera albane
un peu plus tard vous parliez justement
delà de la vision pour les cons les
français de de marine le pen elle est
moins clivant de quelque part dieu
qu'eric zemmour alors elles restent
elles restent clivante 1 les deux reste
quand même très très clivant dans
l'ensemble de l'opinion beaucoup moins
dans leur camp évidemment mais marine le
pen a une image qui est légèrement
meilleure que celle d'eric zemmour dans
le sondage que vous avez publié ce matin
elle paraît un petit peu plus
sympathique deux fois plus sympathique
que lui deux fois plus courageuse deux
fois plus compétentes aussi
elle est en mesure aussi de gagner la
présidentielle de diriger la france
alors on voit bien qu'il ya une
amélioration de son image qui reste
quand même problématique le meeting le
débat pardon de l'entre-deux-tours de
2017 est vraiment un acte lourd en terme
de communication quelque chose qui la
définit en propre et ça reste un vrai
handicap pour elle elle doit aussi
aujourd'hui c'est peut-être l'un de ses
défis tenter d'instaurer une forme de
compétences montrer qu'elle est à la
hauteur de la fonction présidentielle
mais voilà une image qui s'est améliorée
notamment je tirais sur le plan humain
est le côté relationnel elle paraît plus
proche des préoccupations des français
plus sympathique aussi on sait qu'elle a
vu cette stratégie de communication de
lever un peu le voile sur sa vie
personnelle de parler de ses passions
2 voilà de se montrer aussi sous un jour
un peu plus humain eh bien ça ça porte
ses fruits et peut-être ça crée un petit
peu d'empathie avec une partie de
l'électorat et qui ment continuera en
parler un peu plus tard on va retrouver
albane qui est sur place du coup arras
albane on a entendu des chants des cris
est ce que le meeting a l'air de
commencer de se mettre en place
l'ambiance commence à monter
oui tout à fait les militants vous
l'entendez cris marine présidente marine
présidente in solesmes et agitent leurs
bras pour français on voit également des
drapeaux blancs ornés d'une m marine
pour la france et des drapeaux bleus
avec marc et marées le président qui
vous le voyez vous voyez alors là il est
évidemment une slim sera toi mais ils
attendent le premier discours la
première prise de parole qui ne devrait
pas tarder à arriver et les
ddc dernière minute ils étaient tous
levés en hurlant de maremne président
sous marine présidente et attendre on le
voit
tous dans la salle la première prise de
parole
les premières prises de paroles
effectivement sachant qu'il y en a sept
gyms il me semble bien qu'ils devront et
qui vont émailler un peu l'avant
discours un peu pour faire monter la
sauce on va dire pour avant que marine
le pen arrive et fasse son grand
discours de rentrée comme on le disait
on parlait de 210 pages de sa façon de
se démarquer avec eric zemmour est ce
que elle essaye de jouer une carte plus
social que lui alors je veux absolument
y aller c'est de jouer une carte plus
social que lui et d'ailleurs c'est
attendu par son électorat quand on
regarde les enjeux auxquels son
électorat est sensible la question du
heavy dame en premier on retrouve la
question de l'immigration à hauteur de
65% à 65 % c'est 25 plus 25 points de
plus que ce qu'on observe auprès de
l'ensemble des français donc c'est quand
même très spécifique à l'électorat du
rassemblement national mais ses 21
points de moins que les électeurs d'eric
zemmour les électeurs d'eric zemmour
sont beaucoup plus sensibles à la
question de l'immigration ils sont
également beaucoup plus sensible à la
question de la sécurité qui définit
quand même toujours une attente forte
chez les électeurs du rassemblement
national mais les électeurs de marine le
pen sont très sensibles à la question du
pouvoir d'achat beaucoup plus que ce
eric zemmour ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui
qu'il est défini en propre s'est dit
aussi à la sociologie de cet électorat
on sait que c'est un électorat qui est
beaucoup plus composer deux catégories
populaires d'employés d'ouvriers des
personnes qui peuvent aussi plus de
difficultés financières donc cette
thématique là elle joue elle est très
importante c'est la thématique de cette
élection un pas se tromper d'élection
l'a vraiment le la principale thématique
c'est la question du pouvoir d'achat je
dirais que au moment des élections
régionales on avait quatre thématiques
qui était à peu près au même niveau le
pouvoir d'achat la sécurité
l'immigration
la question de de l'environnement
également là et puis la question
évidemment de la protection sociale de
la santé des retraites en encore
toujours marqué par sept par cette crise
sanitaire là on voit bien depuis depuis
quelques mois
comment la question du pouvoir d'achat
est en train de se détacher des autres
enjeux de l'élection pour s'affirmer
comme le
principal le principal domaine de
préoccupation des français le la
thématique qui comptera le plus pour eux
au moment d'aller voter et ça les
candidats longs mois c'est bien compris
par exemple eric zemmour aujourd'hui
fait son grand discours à la date à la
ligne et le thème était justement le
pouvoir d'achat lui aussi se recentre on
peut dire sur ce sujet là oui mais c'est
une c'est une nécessité puisque il faut
évidemment parler à son électorat donc
pour lui ça implique de parler de la
lutte contre le terrorisme de
l'immigration de des questions de
sécurité mais son électorat aussi est
sensible à cette question de pouvoir
d'achat il pour élargir son socle
électoral mais nécessaire d'aborder
cette thématique là qui sont très
attendues par les français effectivement
tout comme oublier des thématiques très
très très très attendu et comme il y est
aussi ça ça a un peu changé mon
impression parce que il y à il ya un an
les actions régionales c'était pas
vraiment ça alors ça ça a toujours été
important bien évidemment mais là on
apprend que ce thème s'impose de plus en
plus dans la campagne oui et puis alors
sur la longue durée le larousse est un
quand on regarde l'histoire des
élections présidentielles ça a été
pendant très longtemps élection après
élection la question de la lutte contre
le chômage la question de l'emploi qui
était la principale préoccupation en
2002 la sécurité venaient un peu
concurrencé la question de cette
question-là cette question de l'emploi
lala cette élection est atypique de ce
point de vue là parce que c'est la
question du pouvoir d'achat qui a
remplacé la question de l'emploi et de
la lutte contre le chômage ait eu des
progrès sur le front de la lutte contre
le chômage on a un taux de chômage qui a
beaucoup baissé n'est pas encore au taux
de chômage incompressible mais est tout
de même les choses vont beaucoup mieux
dans ce domaine c'est donc la question
du pouvoir d'achat la question des fins
de mois qui a pris le relais aussi parce
que il ya une actualité la hausse des
prix du carburant par exemple les
l'inflation des prix de l'énergie toutes
ces questions là c'est une question de
contexte contribuer à renforcer la
polarisation des électeurs sur la
question du pouvoir d'achat
excessivement merci on à albane qui est
sur place toujours à reims avec un
militant albane je vous laisse
l'interviewer pour voilà
oui tout à fait dans ce sens je suis
avec génie un militant élèves venus
aujourd'hui pour se dire bonjour bonjour
ai dit pourquoi
aujourd'hui non pourquoi êtes vous venu
soutenir marine le pen aujourd'hui je
suis venu ici pour soutenir marine le
pen car tout simplement c'est un
candidat qui pour moi représente peu
plus la confiance en la personne la plus
à même mené le pays aujourd'hui et en
qui on peut avoir le plus confiance
pourquoi vous lui faites confiance à
elle tout particulièrement parce que je
pense que ça fait 20 ans que
qu'elle se bat pour la politique en
france qu elle doit se battre contre un
nom qui a été diabolisé par son père est
donc toujours se battre alain subi
beaucoup de l'agression elle a eu un
attentat dans sa jeunesse et donc je
pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est la personne
qui pour son combat le plus beau nez et
en qui on peut avoir évidemment le plus
confiance merci beaucoup d'amis ont
longtemps maintenant pour entonner
ensemble ils sans doute les premières
prises de parole qui arrive pouvoirs
d'enquêté plus fibre peut-être lancer
son premier discours
merci beaucoup alba nous allons
continuer de suivre activement ses
premières prises de parole qui nous
payent valoir plusieurs avant de marine
le pen parle autour de 18h 18h15
normalement cette cet électeur justement
nous parler de la stratégie de
dédiabolisation de marine le pen comme
on dit stoner ça semble avoir porté ses
fruits petit à petit oui petit à petit
cette image qui cède aussi alors on le
voit aussi dans l'est dans les
intentions de vote de second tour par
exemple les intentions de vote de second
tour il faut prendre ça avec encore plus
de précautions que les intentions de
vote du premier tour donc le premier
tournant a eu lieu ça reste doublement
hypothétique c'est un peu
vous êtes une bande non mais
vous souvenez au deuxième tour de 2017
marine le pen
est largement battue et aujourd'hui elle
resterait encore largement battu mais
l'écart s'est considérablement
réduit puisque faso au chef de l'état
elle obtiendrait 44% des voix le chef de
l'état serait donc largement réélu face
à la candidate du rassemblement national
mais marine le pen a quand même
sensiblement progressé depuis 2010 est
sûre cet indicateur l'enjeu est
évidemment pour elle c'est d'accéder au
second tour et la stratégie de
dédiabolisation
justement visa à normaliser et à
empêcher la réédition du front
républicain c'est ça qui lui avait porté
préjudice lors de et puis la question du
débat évidemment mais lors de la
dernière élection c'est vraiment ça qui
lui avait porté préjudice elle tente
depuis plusieurs années maintenant de
désamorcer la constitution d'un ouvre
aux d'un nouveau front républicain et
est ce que cette stratégie est payante
on a vu par exemple à gauche où on
arrête par exemple de vouloir faire
systématiquement barrage à droite aussi
peut-être est-ce que ça marche le long
terme
oui et non oui parce que les indicateurs
se resserre un peu non parce qu'on l'a
vu encore aux dernières élections
régionales en provence alpes côte d'azur
quand il y a un candidat du
rassemblement national qui est en mesure
d'emporter un exécutif régional un
exécutif régional parle pas de la
présidence de la république on a une
mobilisation extrêmement forte pour
faire barrage à cette élue donc le front
républicain a encore une vraie
consistance et un vrai fonctionnement on
imagine bien que ce qui se produit au
niveau local dans une région qui a quand
même très favorables historiquement au
rassemblement national pourrait se
produire de la même façon et sans doute
avec beaucoup plus d'ampleur au niveau
national certes le front républicain
fonctionne peut-être moins mais je crois
que les élections régionales nous ont
montré qu'ils conservaient quand même
une efficacité redoutable
effectivement alors que les prises de
paroles viennent de débuter il me semble
avec hervé fabre aubrespy qui parle en
ce moment sur la chaîne youtube est ce
qu'on peut peut-être l'écouté pour se
pose pour pour cette première prise de
parole il y aura sept intervenants et
c'est le premier
jour était gaulliste fidèle aux idées du
général de gaulle jeu l'était depuis
l'école primaire
l'époque de l'élection présidentielle de
j'ai été ensuite en 1974 aux côtés de
jacques chaban delmas était la bourse du
travail à l'époque à lyon
la nouvelle société j'ai été ensuite aux
côtés de jacques chirac à la fondation
du rpr pantin ya 44 ans 11 février
1978 cent mille personnes
c'était le peuple de france comme vous
aujourd'hui ici à reims autour de marine
le pen
[Applaudissements]
je suis aujourd'hui avec une écharpe
mais ce mec passagers n'ayez pas une
attelle n'ayez pas peur tout ça va aller
très bien dans quelques instants j'ai
été au cabinet effectivement france
antilles dont charles pasqua j'ai et
était aussi mère dans une commune des
bouches du rhône j'ai rejoint au moment
des élections régionales le mouvement
gaulliste l'avenir français et qui
entourent marine le pen et qu'elle a
accepté parce qu'elles vont le
rassemblement sur la liste de thierry
mariani aux élections régionales je suis
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
je suis maintenant conseiller régional
je vais vous le dire j'ai donné ce matin
mon parrainage à marine le pen
[Applaudissements]
parce que
parce que je me sens de l'honneur de la
finalité c'est vous des électeurs comme
vous qui nous avez élu qui me l'avait
élu pour faire élire marine le pen je me
dois je me devais de lui apporter mon
parrainage et de la soutenir à
l'élection présidentielle
[Applaudissements]
à
ai-je à vic j'invite aujourd'hui tous
les gaullistes qu'il s'était olivier
hairault rhdp à heller à l'ump à venir
nous rejoindre votre place beauvau
classe
[Applaudissements]
votre place pêcheurs compagnon elle est
ici aux côtés de celle qui défend la
france et qui va défendre les français
qui va leur redonner du pouvoir d'achat
et redresser la force
j'ai deux raisons essentielles la super
d'abord pascal un projet sérieux
réaliste chiffrer ce projet il a été
fait par des spécialistes des magistrats
des diplomates et des juristes il m'a
fait penser chère marine aux experts
c'était au tour d'edouard balladur quand
on préparait la cohabitation et le
programme rpr udf mais il ya une grande
différence c'est que ce programme
ces mesures elles seront appliquées
quand marine sera élu
dans un gouvernement d'union nationale
celui qu'elle souhaite dans un
gouvernement d'union nationale
avec des conseillers qui seront des
conseillers politiques et n'ont pas
détecté grade
il y aura le référendum qui permettra
d'arrêter l'immigration qui permettra de
passe que vous l'aurez décider qui
permettra de limiter l'acquisition de la
nationalité française
il donnera la préférence aux français
pour toutes les prestations sociales
il n'y aura
[Applaudissements]
il y aura des lois des ordonnances et
les écrins qui permet trop
effet répondre appliquer le programme
immédiatement deuxième raison la
personnalité de marine le pen on le dit
souvent c'est sa troisième candidature à
l'élection présidentielle et ceux qui
ont une mémoire politique la marque pour
cela mais souvenez-vous ça parlait de
françois mitterrand élu à la troisième
tentative de jacques chirac élu en 1995
alors que tout le monde ne croyait
perdus battus ont représenté aux
guignols avec des poignards dans le dos
et bien c'est sur cette radio qui ont
fait élire
[Musique]
par ce que
parce que les électeurs ils préfèrent
les hommes et les femmes de conviction à
ceux qui font des calculs politiques sur
l'avenir et qui renient leurs
engagements
marie le pen peut mais notre territoire
alors là parcourus chaque département
chaque grande ville et elle ne fait
aujourd'hui encore elle en connaît les
habitants et elle les aime on a déjà
connu l'expérience d'un président qui
n'avait aucune connaissance ni montazeri
du territoire français et des français
et même alizés au g10 qui a osé dire
qu'ils avaient appris à aimer les
français n' y avec marine le pen s'est
tenue sur les pas nécessaires elle aime
les français elle leur parle avec amour
affection
et elle veut les rassembler elle peut
les rassembler avec elle il n'y aura pas
de scandale avec monsieur macro dix
ministres ont été évincés du pouvoir ou
en examen
les procureurs de la république à
diviser les français ni acté gilet jaune
il a contraint les forces de l'ordre à
s'opposer aux français
sauvez vous aussi de la crise sanitaire
nouilles a dit qu'il allait vous
emmerder
[Musique]
ceci étant dit d'un président de la
république avec marine le pen vous aurez
une présidente qui aiment les français
alors je vous le dis n'ayez pas peur
n'ayez pas peur de vos collections
n'ayez pas peur de votre vote mais ayez
pas peur de vos démarches pour les
convaincre les électeurs ayez confiance
en notre candidate vous allez faut
mobiliser pour la victoire
avec elle vous fera gagner marine le pen
pour faire gagner la france
voilà c'était le discours d'hervé favre
aubrespy conseil régional de provence
alpes côte d'azur a été sur la liste de
thierry mariani lors des dernières
régionales il apparaît d'une question
assez intéressante c'est celle des
parrainages puisque comme chaque comme
chaque élection présidentielle marine le
pen a des problèmes pour récolter ses
parrainages et maintenant se retrouve
dans la course avec eric zemmour qui lui
aussi à ce souci là oui vous savez que
le conseil constitutionnel depuis cette
semaine annonce le décompte des
parrainages reçu deux fois par semaine
le mardi et le jeudi le dernier décompte
nous indique que marine le pen n'a reçu
pour l'instant que 35 parrainage c'est
un score qui est très faible 1 35
parrainage eric zemmour lui est à 58
parrainage c'est beaucoup moins que jean
luc mélenchon une centaine de parrainage
beaucoup moins que valérie pécresse
324 parrainage
beaucoup moins que yannick jadot aussi
80 parrainage même si c'est difficile
aussi pour le candidat d'europe écologie
les verts donc là il ya une vraie
difficulté pour pour marine le pen alors
il ya un réseau d'élus peut-être que
tout ça aussi et mise en scène est sans
doute que on est vraiment là au tout
début donc sans doute que les
parrainages vont voir arriver dans les
jours qui viennent mais c'est une vraie
c'est une vraie difficulté qu'il faut
pas le nier notamment parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de candidats qui sont sur un
sur un créneau politique relativement
proche regardez le nombre de parrainages
de nicolas dupont aignan 77 le nombre de
parrainages de françois asselineau 56
donc c'est plus que ceux de marine le
pen et puis ce sont donc autant de
parrainage qu'elle ne peut pas collecter
pour elle même est ce que justement ça
va créer un c'est
le sait tous les cinq ans il ya ce
problème là pour marine le pen est-ce
que ça annonce vraiment une collecte
compliqué ou est ce qu elle n'était pas
aussi dans d'en jouer un peu comme
argument alors là c'est sans doute un
peu les
les deux éléments sont sans doute sont
sans doute vrai il ya quand même une
difficulté pour ce type de candidats à
obtenir ses parrainages surtout depuis
que maintenant la liste des parrainages
est transparente est officielle et donc
les maires sont encore plus réticents à
parrainer ce type de nos candidats au
niveau local ça peut avoir des
répercussions
par exemple dans les structures
intercommunales il peut y avoir aussi
des pressions politiques de la part des
villes centres sur les sur les maires
des petites communes pour
pour empêcher ou pour rendre plus
difficile l'attribution de parrainage à
ce type de deux candidats
en tout cas effectivement elle va elle
va sans doute essayer de
d'exploiter cette difficulté au plan
plan médiatique
mais voilà c'était déjà difficile pour
pour son père c'était difficile à de
nombreuses reprises pour elle ça reste
une barrière à l'entrée dans l'élection
présidentielle bien sûr parce que ça
signifie le fait que c'est ce qu'on a
beaucoup reproché à son parti ne pas
être assez implanté localement oui bien
sûr ça renvoie ça renvoie aussi à
l'image de ce parti qui reste quand même
partie avec une image encore sulfureuse
ce n'est pas un parti comme les autres
il ya une proportion importante de la
population française qui majoritaire qui
considère que ce parti est un danger
pour la démocratie
alors ça c'est à beaucoup affaibli au
cours d 1ère année
mais tout de même ça reste un
positionnement une image très atypique
et ça ça vient handicapées la collecte
des parrainages effectivement il ya
aussi une autre question qui a certes un
pas intéressant dois parler avec fabre
au respect c'est de mobiliser les
personnes arrivées à mobiliser les
électeurs qui finalement ne vote plus
les abstentionnistes est ce que c'est le
gros enjeu pour marine le pen face à
eric zemmour oui bien sûr ça c'est un
enjeu c'est toujours un enjeu dans
toutes les campagnes électorales peu
moins dans l'élection présidentielle
parce qu'on est des taux de
participation qui sont beaucoup plus
élevés en fait on a historiquement
toujours un un découplage qui s'est
d'ailleurs peut être encore accrue entre
d'un côté l'élection présidentielle qui
est l'élection reine celle qui mobilise
le plus parce que c'est la clé de voûte
des institutions et on élit la personne
qui a le plus de pouvoir donc là les
électeurs se mobilisent pour les
scrutins dits intermédiaires les
sections régionales départementales même
les municipales maintenant
il ya moins de mobilisation peut-être
qu'on connaît moins ses institutions
conseil régional ça paraît un peu peu
obscur conseil départemental on
méconnaît son rôle exact donc il ya
moins de deux mois de mobilisation mais
c'est une donc c'est un c'est un enjeu
dans toutes les élections de mobiliser
les abstentionnistes c'est encore plus
un enjeu dans cette élection parce qu'on
a battu des records d'abstention au
cours des scrutins précédents et je
dirais que c'est un enjeu encore plus
pour le rassemblement national on a bien
vu aux dernières élections régionales
que sa base électorale ne s'étaient pas
déplacés pour
pour voter pour les candidats du
rassemblement national est-ce que c'est
lié à l'élection est ce que c'est lié
aux candidats qui n'avaient pas la même
stature et la même notoriété que marine
le pen est ce que c'est lié à la crise
du coc vide aussi
ou est ce que c'est une tendance de fond
en tout cas il ya là quelque chose que
doit régler marine le pen il faut
vraiment s'assurer pour elle d'être en
mesure d'activer son socle électoral et
qu'ils viennent bien voter le jour de
l'élection effectivement et c'est
souvent ça qui est compliqué est-ce que
l'on s'attend à une élection 2022 avec
un taux de participation plus bas ou
est-ce que c'est beaucoup trop tôt pour
savoir alors c'est encore vraiment trop
tôt pour le dire on est au début de la
phase active de la campagne les premiers
meetings on vient de le dire commence
seulement maintenant
le but une campagne électorale s'est
justement d'abord d'informer il va y
avoir une élection
est de mobiliser les électeurs donc nous
c'est un indicateur évidemment que nous
regarderons permanence mais on
commencera vraiment avoir une idée très
précise des contours de l'abstention
dans les quinze derniers jours c'est
qu'il ya une partie importante des
électeurs qui décident d'aller voter ou
pas le jour même du scrutin donc c'est
un phénomène l'abstention qui reste
encore très difficile pour les pour les
instituts de sondage à mesurer parce que
c'est un phénomène d'humeur qui voilà
qui a des causes multiples mais pour
l'instant il est vraiment encore trop
tôt pour bien l'appréhender justement
sur cette campagne est sûre on
al'impression fort longtemps en tout cas
beaucoup pour l'instant ces suicides ont
dit d'une campagne qui a du mal à
démarrer est ce que c'est à cause du
conflit est ce que c'est quelque chose
dont vous avez aussi l'impression
oui et non on a vu tout au cours du mois
de janvier
progresser l'indicateur de suivi
des français à l'égard de l'élection
présidentielle ils s'intéressent de plus
en plus aux candidats au débat électoral
54% en début janvier 64 % dans notre
dernière mesure
cette semaine donc y'a quand même un
voilà un intérêt croissant des français
pour pour l'élection ça ne veut pas dire
que l'élection est intéressante
mais on commence à avoir des français
qui s'intéressent de plus en plus aux
débats au débat électoral en revanche et
c'est peut-être ce que vous faisiez
référence les courbes d'intentions de
vote restent particulièrement stable
pour les principaux candidats quand vous
regardez la courbe des manuels macron
tout mois de janvier elle oscille entre
24 25 % très très peu de variation même
chose pour marine le pen même chose pour
celle de valérie pécresse pour élire
pour eric zemmour quelques points de
progression n'est finalement pas sans
commune mesure avec tes dynamique qu'il
avait connue voilà le seul candidat qui
a chuté dans les intentions de vote
c'est yannick jadot est passé de 8 à 4%
mais en raison de l'émergence de
christiane taubira hormis ce point très
très peu d'évolution au mois de janvier
c'est lié à la crise co-lead qu'un peu
gelé les choses et puis il ya évidemment
une forme d'attentisme de l'opinion
avant l'entrée encore dit la thur
d'emmanuel macro et manquant même dans
cette élection un acteur central
effectivement le le président qui ne
s'est pas encore déclaré candidat et qui
met un peu tout ça en pause alors que à
l'écran voyez andrea quotas rac qui
parle en ce moment draka de coco tayrac
anciens de la france insoumise qui a
rejoint le rn et qui est conseiller
régional en auvergne et rhône-alpes
depuis 2015 on va rejoindre albane sur
le terrain albane qui est avec un
militant en ce moment albane pourquoi ce
poids ce militant es là est peut être
pour vous pouvez lui poser la question
c'est son rapport pop pourquoi marine le
pen plutôt qu'eric zemmour
oui tout à fait dans ce sens je suis
avec eux cédric cédric qui avait lu de
lyon pour soutenir mayenne lorraine
aujourd'hui et c'est vrai que c'était
pour vous dire pourquoi c'était vous
plus particulièrement marine le pen avec
eux et eric zemmour par exemple marine
le pen déjà depuis depuis de plusieurs
années le soutien nationaliste enfin la
france voilà c'est d'abord la priorité
nationale plutôt que la priorité
européenne ou même mondialistes
de plus de 10 ans que je milite jeu
toujours plein de regarder des
programmes et je reviens toujours sur
marine le pen voilà c'est la seule
tandis que c'est un set qui veut sauver
la france alors que certains comme
ailier non ils veulent juste très la
droite en faisant une histoire de
l'union des droites mais voilà nous la
france c'est la priorité je sais pas ça
de réponse tombe enfin
en ile-de-france avec est le 6ème temps
à chaque meeting on passe plusieurs
jours et voilà ça permet de viser nos
beaux monuments qui
merci beaucoup cédric g
c'était cette réponse
pour ses interviews de militants on va
peut-être passer sur andrea quotas qui
est en train de parler à la tribune
normalement je vais demander en régie
elle julien de voir s'il peut passer le
conseil régional d'auvergne et
rhône-alpes qui est en train de parler
en ce moment
cette gauche française c'est l'idiot
utile du medef aujourd'hui elle est
passée d'une pause sociale à être gauche
raciale la justice sociale c'est assez
simple c'est ne laisser aucun français
sur le bord de la route mais ces
gauchistes sont obsédés par un seul
endroit les banlieues là on a déjà versé
400 milliards d'euros de politique de la
ville pour un résultat comme vous savez
qui est catastrophique
mais cette gauche elle a oublié les 60 %
de chômage chez les jeunes dans le
bassin minier elle a oublié les 13%
personnes vivantes ou du seuil de
pauvreté en auvergne cette gauche à
l'abandonner la justice sociale vous
vous souvenez peut-être de monsieur
cahuzac
ce ministre socialiste qui était en
charge de la fraude fiscale mais qui
lui-même fraude et est fiscalement
et bien cette gauche c'est la même chose
avec la justice sociale elle en parle
chaque jour mais elle fait l inverse au
quotidien
la gauche
a abandonné
cahuzac et à la fraude sociale ce que la
gauche et tara justice sociale
contrevient comprenez bien les amis que
cette gauche laïque républicaine sociale
patriote est morte et si je reste voyez
ce massacre est vôtre est
incontestablement incontestablement par
une le pen en 2022
pour la laïcité et la justice rend la
justice sociale et de l'amour de la
france
pour finir les amis lorsque vous vous
avez rejoint un insoumis m'avait promis
sur twitter que je finirais dans les
poubelles de l'histoire en étant avec
vous
et bien
[Musique]
deux ans après en voyant leurs
soumissions en voyant leurs reniements
renvoyant en rab en dons de la justice
sociale jeudi à cette gauche qui s'est
autodétruite que je leur laisse
désormais la place sonne dans les
poubelles de la france
et pour conclure les anime si je
condamne fermement l'islamo gauchisme je
vous savez je ne suis en aucun cas pour
l'union de la droite pourquoi parce que
vous les voyez les mêmes à droite les
bédié l air qui prêche dans une mosquée
en pleine période électorale les as bad
qui se font photographier dans les
mosquées à ambérieu en bugey où monsieur
bertrand qui finance des radios
communautariste je n'ai pas quitté cette
gauche indigne pour rejoindre les mêmes
clientéliste qui sont à droite je veux
avec marine sauver la france
et ils dernière fois ci le système nous
attaquent frontalement ces jours ci s'il
vous disent que marine le pen est
raciste alors que tout l'outre-mer
votent pour elle si elle vous dit s'il
vous disent que marine le pen est
antisociale alors que les ouvriers
votent pour elle si se contredisent le
même entre eux en dix ans les uns à
gauche que marine le pen est une
bourgeoise les autres que c'est une
prolétaire enfermés dans un ghetto de
briller s'il vous font ça c'est pour
vous faire douter et s'ils vont faire
douter c'est parce que marine peut
l'emporter
le système nous laissera aucun cadeau il
ne tournera pas le pouvoir
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
des amis
le système ne nous laissera pas le
pouvoir il ne nous reste rien nous
battre à convaincre et à travailler
souvenez vous bien de ces mots du poète
brest celui qui se bat peut perdre mais
celui qui ne se bat pas lui il a déjà
perdu alors battons nous
[Applaudissements]
tu viens de parler comment cet ancien
membre de la france a soumis ce qui à
rejoindre marine le pen c'est quelque
chose qui est assez assez rare et c'est
quelque chose qui n'a pas beaucoup
d'autres qui ont fait ça malgré la
proximité qu'on dit parfois entre
l'extrême gauche et l'extrême droite
quand on voit bien comment le plateau
des différents intervenants a été
constitué on a eu un ancien militant
gaulliste historique
proche de charles pasqua qui a rallié
marine le pen récemment là on a
quelqu'un qui vient de s'exprimer et qui
initialement était du côté de la france
insoumise donc voilà l'effet vise ici a
montré que de la même façon qu'il peut y
avoir des personnes qui quittent marine
le pen ya aussi des personnes qui l'ont
rejoint et que au final les choses
s'équilibrent je crois que c'est
vraiment ça le message qui veut être
envoyés ici dans la composition de des
prises de parole c'est toujours une
question de garder la dynamique d'avoir
une dynamique justement dans les
sondages est-ce qu'il vaut mieux
commencer au où être un peu plus bas et
monter petit à petit ou est-ce qu'il ya
pas de recette miracle n'est absolument
pas une règle
vous savez quand vous regardez les
sondages d'intentions de vote de
françois mitterrand 88 sa courbe était
un niveau très élevé elle est restée
relativement plate pendant toute la
campagne il ya évidemment d'autres
candidats qu'ont connu des dynamiques
des ascensions très très forte puis
d'autres qui se sont effondrés
évidemment la dynamique un effet
médiatique qui est très impactant parce
que c'est très symbolique de ce qui est
une campagne électorale il campagne
électorale s'est rassemblé des électeurs
et ses soutiens on le voit dans les
meetings doit y avoir de la ferveur doit
y avoir de l'affluence doit les y avoir
une forme de justement de d'entousiasme
et puis on doit le voir aussi dans les
courbes avec un candidat qui progresse
c'est quand même quelque chose de très
impressionnant et qui correspond
vraiment sens profond de l'élection
présidentielle qui consiste à rassembler
à agréger les électeurs vous avez parlé
justement tout à l'heure d'eric zemmour
qui a fait une percée historique vous
nous tend pas être tout à l'heure est-ce
qu'il ya d'autres candidats comme ça
peut-être emmanuel macron par exemple en
2017 ou d'autres candidats que l'on peut
penser qu'ils ont fait aussi ses percée
très importante oui il ya des évolutions
très très forte évidemment emmanuel
macron emmanuel macron qui a bénéficié
en février du ralliement de françois
bayrou l'offre d'alliance lefranc au
bâillon pour reprendre son expression à
l'époque c'est lui a permis de gagner 4
à 5 points vous voyez que ça n'a rien à
voir avec les ralliements dont
bénéficient ou pas d'ailleurs eric
zemmour aujourd'hui en tout cas dont il
bénéficie faiblement et à l'époque ça
avait permis à emmanuel macron de se
détacher de françois fillon est
d'assurer sa qualification pour le
second tour face à marine le pen donc ça
avait été vraiment un élément décisif
dans sa campagne électorale on se
rappelle aussi évidemment
de l'ascension enfin du
retour de jacques chirac en 95 et du
plongeon de d'edouard balladur la
progression de jean luc mélenchon au
détriment de benoît hamon 2017 dans
toutes les élections il ya souvent ce
type de dynamique elles sont plus ou
moins marqué mais voilà ça existe parce
que justement le rôle d'une campagne
électorale c'est d'informer et de
transformer les préférences électorales
des des citoyens et de soûlards émerger
justement des questions pour les pour
les candidats écrit de faire émerger des
questions pour les candidats est ce
qu'on voit très bien c'est que ce genre
de transfert se fait entre des candidats
dont les électorats sont très poreux là
ça se fait entre marine le pen et eric
zemmour est passé de 1,6 à 18% quand
eric zemmour progresser jusqu'à 13% mais
oui sur les sur l'échiquier sont très
très proches donc ce sont des électeurs
qui se déplacent mais il n'y a pas un
déplacement d'un côté à l'autre de de
l'axé gauche droite on va reparler juste
après on a albanais qui est actuellement
avec un conseiller régional du
rassemblement national albane je vous
laisse la main pour cette interview
oui tout à fait dans ce sens je suis
avec jean baptiste marie qui est
conseiller régional d'île de france jean
baptiste marie dites nous comment marine
le pen peut faire face aujourd'hui à
eric zemmour dans cette campagne
présidentielle alors moi qui suis je
vous le dis moi qui suis dans le
mouvement patriote depuis 2009 j'ai fait
trois causes c'est la troisième campagne
présidentielle effectivement que je fais
et je le vois que cette année en fait
plus que jamais au delà des et des
petits échecs 2017 marina le programme
le plus rassembleur on le voit sur le
terrain on a de la chance que le front
national et leur ascendance russell est
mis sur le devant de la scène le provost
le problème migratoire français et du
coup on a une prédominance en son
souvenir et je pense que l'essentiel en
crète d'axer notre discours sur les
autres sujets notamment le 10 sport
social parce qu'on le voit que depuis
2010 est emmanuel ma trois ans après à
scinder les français en plusieurs
catégories les pauvres contre les riches
les gens qui sont les
ciné-rencontres ceux qui travaillent les
gens qui passent dans les gares les gens
qui ne sont rien effectivement je pense
que le projet est aujourd'hui le plus
rassembleur c'est derrière marine le pen
peu importe que les certains candidats
effectivement
près des idées un peu plus radical en
appuyant sur ces thématiques migratoire
alors qu'on a la prédominance sur ce jeu
depuis des dizaines d'années
sur sa société mère on observe t elle
des défections au sein du rassemblement
national des dernières semaines est-ce
que vous pensez que ça pourrait
affaiblir marine le pen alors tout
d'abord je pense que les défections sont
très minimes par rapport au nombre
d'élus qui a localement sur tout le
territoire français et puis je vous dire
quelque chose quand quand on démissionne
quand on vient du canton est de voir
andré cot arak de l'a300 soumise la
moindre des choses c'est de rendre c'est
de rendre son mandat donc moi je
n'aurais de respect que pour les ai vus
qu'ils démissionnent de leur mandat
merci beaucoup j'en mets tous mariés
pourraient cette interview les anglais
c'est suivre les discours qui vont se
dérouler jusqu'à la fin de l'après midi
[Musique]
merci beaucoup albane pour cette
interview justement le sud de ce conseil
régional nous parler d'une chose on a
déjà un peu parlé c'est le
positionnement de marine le pen sur la
question sociétale pour se démarquer
d'eric zemmour oui on voit bien que là
c'est un des axes qui lui enfin qu'elle
cherche à présenter pour se démarquer
d'eric zemmour il y en a d'autres il ya
aussi une question de style on a bien vu
dans l'interview que vous avez publié
que elle cherchait incarner une nuance
dans le discours face à des propos
qu'elle qualifie de violents qu'elle
veut incarner un esprit de sérieux le
sens des responsabilités face à
quelqu'un qui ferait des propositions
irréalistes qu'elle cherche aussi à
incarner une proximité avec les
électeurs une compréhension des
préoccupations des français alors
qu'eric zemmour serait un candidat un
peu
de l'élite et des plateaux médiatique
qu'elle veut faire des propositions
concrètes pragmatiques
tangible des propositions du quotidien
alors que zemmour pour elle de son point
de vue serait plutôt dans une forme
d'intellectualisme de propositions
strictement théorique
bref y'a aussi quand même cette question
de style qu'elle veut qu'elle veut
incarner et bien montrer ses différences
à travers un propos oui plus sérieux
plus responsable démontré aussi sa
compétence cette présidentialité qu'elle
essaye de
d'acquérir et et en même temps de se
différencier d'eric zemmour et de le
renvoyer dans une image encore plus
négatif on al'impression justement qui
elle que les reproches qu'elle formule
eric zemmour s'était des reproches qu'on
lui formuler avant c'est parce qu'elle
dit est de se recentrer en fait oui
c'est ça qui est très surprenant on l'a
bien vu d'ailleurs avec cette évocation
du terme nazi qui est quelque chose qui
a été reproché depuis l'origine au front
national puis rassemblement national
d'utiliser sa contre eric zemmour ça
montre bien qu'il ya eu 1
un renversement des rôles d'une certaine
manière et que eric zemmour occupe
désormais la place que jean marie le pen
puis marine le pen veut occuper sur
l'échiquier politique qui est la place
ils ont deux formes d'épouvantail
politique et que l par conséquence salsa
la recentre et sa adouci son image alors
ça la transforme pas radicalement ça ne
vient pas une image extrêmement positive
du jour au lendemain mais ça a un effet
adoucissant si je puis dire sur sur
l'image de la candidate activement on va
écouter daniel zaïdani qui est en train
de parler en ce moment c'est l'ancien
président du conseil général de mayotte
entre 2011 et 2015 sans étiquette il
avait appelé à voter berrou en 2012 et
en décembre 2021 il avait annoncé son
soutien à marine le pen donc c'est
encore un autre transfuge on va dire
qu'il éclaire joie et la justice nous
voilà maintenant livrer en pâture aux
voyous et au criminel
ma chère marine
entre portant l'elysée tu dois être
l'électrochoc qui permettra de retrouver
le plaisir de vivre en france
[Applaudissements]
abete a créé avec ta crédibilité sur les
questions de l'outre-mer
plus rien et a démontré des
interventions sur mayotte sont constants
rigoureux travailler et précis
tu n'attends pas la période électorale
pour porter un regard sur notre mère
comme certains te soutenir ici c'est
tout un symbole pour moi français de la
diversité
[Applaudissements]
de choisir comme candidate pour la
présidence de la république peut
paraître surprenant qu ont certains mais
pour moi c'est une évidence
ta porte
ton énergie ton courage ta détermination
ta volonté son désir profond de
redresser la france en rassemblant tous
les français m'ont
convaincu
[Applaudissements]
nous attendons de toi que tu
rétablissent l'ordre juste mais rétablir
l'ordre c'est d'abord rétablir la
sécurité
nous sommes lassés de vivre dans la peur
d'être agressés voire assassinés
[Applaudissements]
l'impunité des criminels des délinquants
doit cesser
il apparaît nécessaire de réorganiser
les forces de l'ordre sur le territoire
en leur accordant plus de moyens humains
et financiers
la justice doit s'adapter à la réalité
de la délinquance en particulier de la
délinquance des mineurs
nous devons reconquérir l'ensemble de
notre territoire français en mettant fin
aux endroits
[Applaudissements]
avec talent ou un programme pour
l'outre-mer nous allons enfin pouvoir
sécuriser l'île de mayotte relancer le
système scolaire et respecter le pacte
sanitaires un territoire qui perd sa
jeunesse c'est un territoire qui perd sa
vitalité aussi avec cette loi nous
pourrons soutenir la création
d'entreprises grâce à la défiscalisation
et aux zones franches vous l'aurez
compris l'enjeu de ces élections
présidentielles c'est de sauver le pays
et sont en outre mer
[Applaudissements]
marine
la france a besoin de toi
marie
nous avons besoin de toi
marine
l'outre-mer a besoin de toi
marine mayotte a besoin de toi
alors chers amis pour la france pour
l'outre-mer pour malades les 10 et le 24
rouge avril prochain allons tous
ensemble porter marine à l'elysée
[Applaudissements]
merci merci et fait en sorte que demain
cela devienne une réalité marine aime la
france marine m l'outre-mer marine et
mayotte dans la france
merci
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup
quel beau témoignage
j'ai un petit quizz pour toi est ce que
tu sais comment on dit ça suffit en
portugais et bien sûr laurent on dit
chez gars là tu va bluffer c'était
moyens suivants
voilà c'était le discours de daniel
zaïdani conseil général de mayotte qui a
parlé d'un point assez intéressant
justement c'est le vote des jeunes
arriver à mobiliser les jeunes on sait
que marine le pen elle plaît à un
électorat jeune mais emmanuel macron
aussi comment se passe un peu le combat
sur ce terrain là vous avez raison de
parler de combat c'est une cible
électorale qui est très importante à
voir la jeunesse avec soin pour un
candidat c'est vraiment un atout alors
quand on regarde les intentions de vote
vous savez nous dans les études
d'opinion il ya plusieurs types de
jeunes si je puis dire on a une grande
catégorie des jeunes de moins de 35 ans
et puis au sein de cette catégorie on
regarde les 18 25 ans et les 25 34 et
bien chez les plus jeunes chez les 18 24
ans c'était manuel macron qui est en
tête 26 % alors que chez les 25-34 ans
donc la tranche d'âge juste au dessus
c'est marine le pen qui est en tête 27 %
contre 20 % pour emmanuel macron donc là
on a vraiment un duel au sein de la
grande catégorie des jeunes entre
emmanuel macron et marine le pen
emmanuel macron qui en fait séduit
davantage les jeunes qui sont encore
dans le monde universitaire qui sont
encore voilà
les peuples aux votants voilà ceux qui
ont voté pour la première exactement les
primo votants qui sont peut-être
qu'ils ont peut-être un
capacité d'identification plus forte
avec un président qui est un président
jeune marine le pen elle séduit les
jeunes qui sont qui viennent d'entrer
sur le marché du travail qui sont en
train de fonder un foyer qui peut être
rencontres toutes les difficultés qu'on
rencontre à cette époque-là de de la vie
mais voilà chacun peut prétendre à
séduire une partie de la jeunesse ce ne
sont pas les mêmes jeunes mais chacun
est en tête dans l'une de ces deux
catégories de jeunes quand on se
rappelle par exemple de la vidéo des
manuels macro avec mac faye et carlito
qui avait qui avait touché beaucoup de
personnes la vidéo sur les gestes
barrières effectivement est-ce que ça
s'ajuste ça doit jouer forcément où on a
du mal à le savoir ça plutôt des effets
d'image que des effets électoraux
ça peut renforcer justement cette
proximité entre un candidat en
l'occurrence président de la république
et une partie des des électeurs les plus
jeunes mais en terme de nombre ces
canaux parle aussi de tweets si on parle
de lattes de tous ces nouveaux médias
tout ça est une audience relativement
limité même s'il peut y avoir des effets
indirects même s'il peut y avoir des
rediffusions sont des contenus qu'ils
restent accessibles en permanence ça
évidemment beaucoup moins de force et
d'impact qu'un grand jt ou qu'une grande
interview dans un dans un quotidien je
pense qu'il faut faire les deux mais
disons qu'avec ces nouveaux médias on va
davantage travailler pour un candidat
du point de vue du marketing électoral
plutôt travailler l'image ou la
proximité avec une cible en particulier
et moins cherché à avoir un impact sur
les intentions de vote c'est surtout sur
les jeunes est ce que sur les sur un peu
plus âgés sur les retraités on parle par
exemple de
2000 et le maquereau comme le candidat
des retraités est ce que c'est vraiment
le cas alors il ya il ya une concurrence
entre emmanuel macron et valérie
pécresse dans ce dans ce domaine et sur
cette cible des personnes de plus de 65
ans qui est un électorat important en
nombre est important parce qu'il est
très civique on sait qu'ils se déplacent
beaucoup plus pour aller voter pendant
longtemps cessé cet électorat qui a
assuré les succès électoraux de la
droite
et pendant quelque temps valérie
pécresse était en tête dans cet
électorat là depuis quelques semaines ce
n'est plus le cas alors elle
conserverait encore le vote de 25% des
électeurs de plus de 65 ans mais 31%
d'entre eux voteraient pour emmanuel
macron si l'élection avait lieu dimanche
donc là il ya vraiment une rivalité
entre la candidate des républicains et
le chef de l'état pour tenter de séduire
cette cible électorale qui est très
importante sinon on va rejoindre albane
sur place albane comment comment est
l'ambiance alors que marine le pen ne
devrait plus maintenant trop tardé à
faire son discours
oui tout à fait les militants
applaudissent en atterrissant cette
dernière parole
avant les autres
tendu notamment jordan marbella et louis
aliot en attendant ils applaudissent
après chaque prise de parole écrit marie
le pen présidente marine présidente et
agitent leurs drapeaux on vient de le
voir je vous l'avais vu sans doute
derrière moi
ils viennent de boue passée une diffusé
un témoignage sur les violences dans la
société ce à quoi les militants ont
applaudi bien
alors que j'imagine que c'est jean paul
garraud qui a dû prendre la parole
écoutez le discours qui s'est poursuivie
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup à evans
c'est jean paul garraud qui est en train
de parler un député ump pendant dix ans
de 2010 à 2012 en 2018 il avait rejoint
le rassemblement national juste avant de
l'écouter on parlait des différentes
classes d'âge pour les actions il ya une
question de de l'abstention qui est qui
et qui était très forte puisque est ce
qu'on peut dire quand même que les
retraités votre plus que les jeunes oui
alors ça c'est très très bien documenté
il ya un réflexe
civique qui est vraiment bien installée
chez les chez les plus âgés et qui
demande encore à
être acquis chez les plus jeunes c'est
un phénomène classique
plus on est âgé plus on se mobilise plus
on s'intéresse à la politique et donc
plus plus on vote et de ce point de vue
là puisque nous mesurons aujourd'hui est
vraiment d'un grand classicisme n'a pas
beaucoup changé par rapport à seulement
par l'afp s'est montré très bien mais
nous allons écouter jean paul garraud
qui est en train de parler en ce moment
vous rappelle du député ump encore un
autre transfuge encore une belle brise
itunes aux prêtres et brûlent nos
églises une idéologie qui crée une
fracture majeure dans la communauté
nationale qui attisent la haine envers
notre pays et ses institutions qui
utilisent les esprits faibles pour des
passages à l'acte solitaire difficile à
prévoir une idéologie fait de radicalité
et d'intransigeance qui est un cauchemar
régressif voulant nier plus d'un
millénaire de progrès la civilisation
une eau théologie qui veut mettre en
place et dictature théocratique
totalitaire avec leur cortège d'horreurs
cette idéologie véritable nazisme du 21e
siècle
céline services mhcs
dès notre arrivée au pouvoir nous lui
ferons la guerre à travers toutes ces
manifestations et je dis bien à travers
toutes ces manifestations pas question
de faire comme les gouvernements
précédents de beaux discours et peu
d'actes des réformes en trompe l'oeil il
ne s'attaque jamais aux racines du mal
qui ne cite même pas l'ennemie des
dirigeants gangréné par le doute des
mondes toutes les décadences disait de
gaulle des dirigeants faible avec les
forts et fort avec les faibles qui manie
la culture de l'excusé dont macro est le
condensé et la caricature des dirigeants
qui sous la pression d'événements
terrible ont pris quelques mesures
contre le terrorisme forme la plus
violente de l'islamisme mais qui ont
oublié la cible principale c'est-à-dire
l'islamisme lui même car les amis en
france aujourd'hui il est interdit
d'être terroriste 1 mais il n'est pas
interdit d'être islamistes
alors les amis plus question d'éviter
justement les questions qui fâchent
certains milieux soi disant
intellectuels et médiatique plus
question de noyer le poisson en plus
question de faire des lois avec de beaux
emballages mais dans le contenu est
totalement inefficace non pas du tout
avec marine présidente de la république
nous donnerons immédiatement la parole
au peuple avec ce référendum sur
l'immigration et la primauté du droit
national afin de ne pas être entravé par
de prétendus juridiction européenne
nous retrouverons notre souveraineté
juridique
la france retrouvera le droit de faire
son droit et nous appliquerons
et nous appliquerons entre arme absolue
contre l'islamisme c'est à dire la
proposition de loi déjà déposée par
marine le pen à l'assemblée nationale
depuis un an qui vise à combattre
l'idéologie islamiste
karl armes de la démocratie c'est la loi
je suis effectivement très heureux
d'avoir participé à l'élaboration ce
texte
véritable bombe nucléaire contre toutes
les manifestations des l'islamisme qui
en deux titres 12 est chapitré 40
articles raillera l'islamisme de la
carte de france
je le dis en tant que citoyen en tant
que citoyen qui aime son pays en tant
que magistrat qui a passé sa vie à
traquer le crime en tant que responsable
politique qui a toujours agi en
conscience cette loi qui est prêt à être
appliquée que nous avons fabriqué clé en
main qui n'attend que d'être promulguée
nous débarrassera de ces fous d'allah
qui veulent nous imposer une société qui
n'est pas la nôtre
nous on est en france on est en france
et on entend bien y rester
[Applaudissements]
et on entend des mois bien entendez moi
bien marine le pen est la seule
candidate à cette élection
présidentielle qui a légiféré en la
matière la seule qui a un projet prêt à
être voté un texte détaillé juridique
complet exhaustif et cela depuis un an
pour tous les autres candidats tous les
autres candidats ce ne sont que des
déclarations d'intention des constats là
rien de concret d'applicable que des
paroles des paroles et encore des
paroles aux nous rend peu plus mais nous
on est prêts
cette loi c'est une arme de guerre
c'est une loi qui met hors la loi
l'islamisme
il ne s'agit évidemment pas de conforter
le respect des principes de la
république comme la piteuse membres
décider le gouvernement il s'agit de
garantir ses principes et surtout très
respecté en interdisant purement et
simplement toute expression
manifestation diffusion d'idéologie
indésirables en république
déjà en 2010 lorsque j'étais le
rapporteur de la loi sur l'interdiction
du voile intégral
j'avais défini ce nouvel ordre social
cette vie à la française validée par le
conseil constitutionnel
muni de tous ces joutes qui juridique
nous pouvons et nous devons bien entendu
aller plus loin ainsi ce droit
d'exception qui dérogera à toutes les
dispositions antérieures contraires et
d'application immédiate
imposera à tous représentants de l'état
à tout magistrat de faire respecter la
loi interdiction de tout financement de
tout signe toutes tenues dignes et à
cette idéologie interdiction de tout
avantage par l'état de tout accès au
maintien dans la fonction publique
interdiction de l'entrée et du maintien
d'un étranger interdition dissolution de
toute association
interdiction de tout regroupement
interdiction d'enregistrer des
candidatures à des élections y compris
professionnelle et syndicale mêmes
possibilités
de déclaré démissionnaire d'office des
candidats élus possibilité nouvelle
donnée au préfet et au recteur de faire
respecter la neutralité de
l'enseignement la protection des
enseignants
interdiction de tout bâtiment de tout
bâtiment
ostentatoire comme et des mines à près
de 30 mètres de haut interdiction
[Applaudissements]
interdiction de tout tenu de tout signe
de nature à manifester cette idéologie
que ce soit dans le public ou dans le
privé dissolution de toute association
possibilités étendues le retrait de la
nationalité
d'interdiction du territoire et de
nombreuses modifications du droit pénal
par le jeu de circonstance aggravante
avec augmentation des peines
impossibilité de prononcer des sursis
les aménagements de peine des peines
complémentaires est attendu comme
l'indignité nationale et ainsi de suite
voilà une proposition
voilà une loi à venir
vraiment vraiment très détaillée très
juridique et on va l'appliquer
[Applaudissements]
cette loi c'est non seulement cette loi
c'est non seulement une affirmation une
affirmation symbolique très forte car il
n'y a plus il n'ya plus de faux fuyants
il n'y a plus de faux semblants c'est un
outil remarquablement et redoutablement
efficace par une approche tous azimuts
de cette influence islamique dans tous
les champs de la vie sociale c'est aussi
un cordon sanitaire placés autour des
pouvoirs publics pour éviter l'entrisme
dans les administrations publiques dans
l'armée dans la police dans l'achat
d'arbres y
cette loi protège protège nos
concitoyens notre mode de vie elle
sanctuary zh notre territoire national
et même notre espace culturel cette loi
est également une garantie pour les
musulmans respectent une loi et loyaux à
notre pays et je prends pour exemple des
harkis qui ont donné leur sang pour la
france
cette loi c'est l'occasion d'une
mobilisation générale
car plus personne n'est dupe des
discours grandiloquents et creux qui
ponctuent chaque agression islamique et
qui signe en même temps et en plus à
chaque fois l'impuissance de l'état
l'affaissement de la natation alors un
seulement mes amis mobilisation générale
autour de marine le pen marine le pen à
l'elysée vite vite
le sursaut national le sursaut national
vive la france vive le france damon
duval
voilà c'était jean paul garraud
d'anciens députés ump de 2002 à 2012 qui
soutient maintenant marine le pen on en
parlait tout à l'heure marine le pen qui
en est à sa troisième candidature
troisième candidature dans une élection
présidentielle ça commence à faire est
ce que il ya un effet par rapport à ça
de
comment on peut dire de l'attitude
quelque part oui en effet il ya un effet
d'usure troisième candidature
présidentielle c'est consécutive
d'ailleurs la troisième candidature
présidentielle consécutive pour jean luc
mélenchon
également et puis il ya plusieurs autres
candidats qui étaient déjà présents dans
2017 nathalie arthaud philippe poutou
nicolas dupont aignan candidat qui
étaient présentes même il ya 20 ans
christiane taubira était candidate à la
présidentielle en 2002 bon il n'y a pas
beaucoup de renouvellement même s'il ya
des des candidats qui se présentent pour
la première fois comme valérie pécresse
ou comme anne hidalgo ce pas à
proprement parler des personnalités
nouvelles en politique il ya eric
zemmour s'est assuré une partie de son
succès s'était fait de nouveautés mais
voilà pour le cas particulier de marine
le pen la troisième élection quand on
fait quand on regarde l'histoire des
élections présidentielles il ya eu huit
présidents de la république
six d'entre eux ont été élus dès leur
première participation il ya deux
candidats qui sont devenus présidents
alors 3e temps tite et anti tentative
pardon c'est françois mitterrand 65 74
80 et c'est jacques chirac 80 88 95
voilà est-ce que dans quels cas se
situera marine le pen est ce que ça ait
de la troisième candidate à être élu à
la troisième tentative ou pas ça nous le
verrons dans les mois qui viennent
effectivement avec ce premier tour qui
se profile il ya thierry mariani qui
devrait pas tarder à remonter sur scène
pour parler on va rejoindre albane boc
qui est sur place albanais ce que ce ce
premier grand nom on va dire sans faire
insulte à ceux qui l'ont précédé
galvanise les foules
oui tout à fait c'est vraiment comme
vous dites le galvanise la ville on le
voit les militants le seul à être
régulièrement et soutiennent laurent
jacot belicchi qui introduit chaque
chaque soldat chaque
[Applaudissements]
salue l'arrivée de thierry mariani en
assumant leur drapeau français mercato
le drapeau marine pour la france ils se
lèvent et applaudissent tous
chaleureusement cette première grosse
grosse prise de parole comme olivier
tiramani était très attendu inde et des
premiers trois points discours avant
louis aliot et jordan bardella je
voulais ce van sant et et poutres sur
emmanuel van effectivement on va
l'écouter dès qu'ils arrivent sur le
plateau et dès que nous avons les images
de la part de la delà de la régie
thierry mariani ancien ministre ump
député il a rallié le rn en 2019 il est
tête de liste aux européennes on écoute
thierry mariani
simplement une chose c'est que chaque
fois qu'on entend dans les médias swing
et le moindre parlementaire en marche
les premières victimes de la violence
politique et j'ai découvert cela en vous
rejoignant ce sont les militants du
rassemblement national
alors c'était
c'était il ya trente ans 92
le référendum sur le traité de
maastricht
philippe seguin a eu cette réflexion qui
est toujours d'actualité
droite et gauche sont devenus deux
détaillants qui s'approvisionnent au
même grossiste
le grossiste ya trente ans c'était
l'europe aujourd'hui c'est le
mondialisme et
chez le même grossiste ne vous trompez
pas on retrouve monsieur macro et madame
pécresse côte à côte dans la queue
elle voudrait se faire passer pour
merkel ou de thatcher en réalité elle
n'est simplement que le clone de macron
une sorte de chamallows politique est là
je la connais bien puisque je les côtoie
ya un certain nombre d'années d'ailleurs
elle était visionnaire elle me disais
que j'aurais mieux de partir pour
rejoindre le rassemblement national pour
une fois je réduis l'écouté plus tôt
elle voulait
valérie pécresse là la même conviction
danser dans la même souplesse dans ses
convictions effectivement que le
chamallow souvenez vous des dernières
primaires aux présidentielles on avait
le torticolis d'abord elle se tenait
fillon après le soutenaient juppé après
elle re soutenait fillon
bref c'est une femme de conviction à qui
vous pouvez faire confiance
c'est
[Musique]
elle se dit de droite mais regardez qui
elle fréquente et vous comprendrez qui
allaient
dans ses amis les plus proches
jordan tu dois bien le connaître
puisqu'il a été avec toi la région ile
de france
monsieur karam monsieur karam s'est
quand même celui qui a trouvé tout à
fait normal de fréquenter mohamed et
niche l'imam de la mosquée de pantin
celui qui diffusait des vidéos
sur monsieur paty et les malheureusement
on a vu comment tout cela a fini c'est
le bras droit de madame pécresse mais
ces compromissions ne s'arrête pas là
souvenez-vous au début c'était je suis
d'accord avec mon ami ciotti et puis une
fois les primaires passé à droite
désormais c'est je trouve sympathique
mon ami lagarde
or en réalité
qui est monsieur lagarde
c'est le représentant parfait de cette
droite qui n'hésite pas à pactiser avec
les islamistes à s'allier avec tous les
communautarismes pour garder ses mandats
son porte parole
sans porte parole ou plutôt le chef de
ses porte parole c'est l'un de nos
collègues au parlement européen le
sympathique geoffroy didier il est
tellement sympathique que je me souviens
il trouvait que lui que nicolas sarkozy
allait trop loin à droite alors il avait
créé la diagonale c'étaient les
sarkozystes de gauche
et monsieur geoffroy didier avait comme
premières propositions pour changer
l'image de la droite une proposition
extraordinaire donner le droit de vote
aux immigrés aux élections locales voilà
quels sont les porte parole voilà quels
sont les amis de madame pécresse et puis
enfin
je constate que quand région provence
alpes côte d'azur
monsieur muselier qui est finalement un
peu pour elle un précurseur
a décidé de faire un accord avec leur
marche bien entendu la condamnation de
madame pécresse
j'ai rien vu venir mais c'est normal
parce que marine quand il sera au
deuxième tour ne fait pas de soucis à
20h01 elle sera la première à rejoindre
emmanuel macron
mais
rien n'est joué rien n'est joué et
certains le disent pourquoi tu soutiens
marine le pen je la soutiens d'abord
parce que maintenant j'ai appris à la
connaître mais je la soutiens aussi et
surtout parce que je veux que la france
se change dans deux mois dans certains
nous expliquent qu'ils se mettent
d'accord pour compte pour construire le
grand parti politique de demain mais je
m'en fous dans cinq ans ou dix sept ans
on sait pas où on saura ce que je veux
c'est gagner donc deux mois est la seule
qui peut gagner dans des mois c'est
marine le pen
et marine
[Applaudissements]
marine tu dois gagner donc de moi parce
que tout le monde est d'accord pour dire
désormais qu'il ya une urgence
climatique mais on oublie les autres
urgences l'urgence sécuritaire et tu as
été tout le monde le reconnaît devant
les policiers du syndicat alliance la
plus précise la plus concrète dans les
mesures que tu proposes est l'urgence
migratoires et cela a été dit nous
sommes les seuls à avoir un projet
applicable dans les premières semaines
qui sera soumis par référendum aux
français l'urgence industrielle d'un
pays qui voit petit à petit ces
entreprises partir et qui veut tout
simplement de son énergie nucléaire de
son industrie nucléaire à l'ensemble de
ses autres énergies garder sa capacité
industrielle et plus l'urgence sociale
l'urgence sociale certains disaient
c'est pas le rôle d'un président de la
république
il suffit pas d'aller faire un meeting
dans le nord pour montrer qu on a une
cible sociale il suffit d'être avec les
français comme tu l'a été depuis des
années depuis des mois pour les comprend
alors
alors dans deux mois
sans lui
écrivait l'histoire de france dans deux
mois avec elle changer l'avenir de la
france dans deux mois rendez la france à
la france rangs des marines mettez la
présidente de la république
[Applaudissements]
quelle convention qu'elle après midi et
je crois qu'on est pas au bout de nos
surprises lors
il est le défenseur de la famille il ne
se laisse pas dicter sa conduite par
l'union on a entendu et ont attendu
thierry mariani thierry mariani une
prise on peut le dire de marine le pen
l'un des plus importants
soutiens de marine le pen qui parlait
aujourd'hui on attend maintenant louis
aliot et jordan bardella qui ne vont pas
tarder à s'exprimer après cette vidéo
vous voyez derrière nous
thierry mariani c'est quand même
quelqu'un pour marine le pen qui a c'est
important parce qu'il avait une stature
nationale weeds ceinture nationale c'est
un proche de nicolas sarkozy
première à tous deuxième atout il a été
ministre et donc effectivement c'était
un ralliement important il a su se faire
une place auprès des militants on voit
bien d'ailleurs que dans les prises de
parole il ya un crescendo et que plus on
approche du discours de la candidate
plus ce sont des potes personnalité de
poids qui qui s'expriment mais c'est
aussi le candidat qui a été battue en
région paca alors même qu'il avait une
véritable chance de l'emporter au début
de la campagne pour les élections
régionales donc rappeler cette cet
événement cette défaite c'est un peu à
double tranchant mais puisque c'est sur
ces élections régionales on se rappelle
que la dernière candidate avait été
marion maréchal-le pen qui vous pouvez
toit avait fait un très très bon score a
été passé pas si loin que ça de
remporter la région oh oui et dans les
deux cas il y avait eu une mobilisation
très forte du front républicain dans
l'en dans l'entre-deux tours qui avait
conduit dans les deux cas à la défaite
du candidat ou de la candidate du
rassemblement national est donc toujours
cette persistance de ce qu'on appelle
communément le plafond de verre s'il
existe au niveau régional pourquoi
est-ce qu'il n'existerait pas où il
n'existerait plus haut niveau national
ça c'est vraiment ce que ce que doit
démontrer marine le pen aujourd'hui on
va faire un petit point timing puisque
marine le pen devait s'exprimer à partir
de 18h15 il est 18 heures 23 il devrait
y avoir normalement deux entreprises de
parole mais aussi très mariani allez
assez rapidement au final n'a pas fait
une prise de parole aussi n'ont que ça
c'est important aussi de bien gérer son
timing parce que l'horaire c'est
important oui l'horaire c'est très
important mais il ya le il ya le
couperet du jt dès 20h donc il faut
laisser le temps aux rédactions des
grandes chaînes de télévision
10 15 minutes pour pouvoir préparer les
sujets est vraiment l'enjeu de ce type
de meetings c'est évidemment ce qui se
passe dans la salle ce qui est relayée
sur sur les réseaux sociaux sur internet
mais les quelques dizaines de secondes
la petite phrase on les petites phrases
qui seront retenus dans les grands jt
parce que c'est là où l'audience et donc
la visibilité sont maximales c'était
aussi ça le combat avec eric zemmour
eric zemmour parlant tôt il fallait pas
qu'elle parle trop tôt mais aussi il
faut pas trop débordé pour les voilà il
ya l'audience sur les chaînes
d'information et puis ensuite il ya
cette présence dans les jt donc là les
interlocuteurs qui viennent vont sans
doute avoir des prises de paroles très
ramassé cinq six sept minutes comme
vient de le faire thierry mariani pour
que marine le pen puisse débuter son
discours très prochainement on va
écouter justement louis aliot le maire
de perpignan ancien député et député au
revers
des réformes ou du cinéma le bilan du
quinquennat est éloquent tout ce que
tant d'autres à l'étranger pouvaient
nous envier il a bradé le pouvoir
d'achat de nos compatriotes baisse de
jour en jour le communautarisme prend
racine dans les métropoles comme dans
les villes moyennes nos agriculteurs
souffrent chaque jour de plus en plus
nos services publics à commencer par
celui de la santé s'appauvrissent au
point d'être pris à la gorge notre école
ne veut parvient plus à jouer son rôle
de creuset républicain
tout ceci n'est pas le fruit du hasard
si le résultat de sa politique
il considère la france comme une part de
marché dans une économie mondialisée où
les géants
où les géants économiques décident à la
place des états bref emmanuel macron
fait des tweets mais il ne conduit
absolument pas les affaires de la nation
et bien c'est cela dont nous ne voulons
plus cela n'est pas la france pour
laquelle le peuple de france attend
bataille et donner son sang mais aussi
fait valoir tout son génie avec marine
cette soumission au diktat de l'alliance
entre technocrates et financier cédera
sa place à l'exemplarité à l' équilibre
des échanges
avec marine nous voulons voir notre
drapeau porteurs de notre identité au
coeur de notre engagement politique et
de nos valeurs de liberté d'égalité et
de fraternité
avec marine
nous sommes persuadé d'une chose ce sont
les françaises et les français
le peuple des citoyens qui sont aptes à
décider du destin de la nation de
l'héritage à transmettre aux générations
futures en avril les citoyens n'auront
pas seulement le choix entre le modèle
des élites est le nôtre ils devront
surtout trancher entre la liquidation ou
bien le renouveau de la france tout le
monde le sait
l'abstention favorise le vote cliente
ait l'air celui des minorités qui décide
pour le plus grand nombre et notre
mission principale est de faire venir
les français aux urnes cette france
cette france
c'est celle de nos villages de nos
villes des gens simples de nos
compatriotes qui se battent au quotidien
pour vivre honnêtement vivre de leur
travail
créer des emplois c'est la france qui
après élections élections nous fait
davantage confiance car elle voir
lorsque nous sommes aux affaires
que nous nous préoccupons de son sort
nous la connaissons bien c'est elle à
hénin beaumont à fréjus au pontet
hayange à béziers mais aussi à perpignan
mes chers amis je ne vous raconte pas
l'histoire de laboratoire politique très
prisé chez les socialistes avec les
résultats que l'on connaît les mères que
nous sommes ne tentons pas d expérience
sur le dos des habitants nous les
respectons trop pour cela nous tentons
avec les moyens qui sont les nôtres avec
les lois de la république de régler les
problèmes d'une classe politique à bout
de souffle il n'a jamais jamais voulu
pardon régler le moindre problème dans
nos villes ou les trafics de drogue les
sécurités la précarité la pauvreté le
communautarisme gangrène le quotidien de
beaucoup de nos compatriotes
nous essayons d'agir concrètement c'est
la france de demain que nous
construirons avec les français et non
pas sans eux ni humiliation ni
infantilisation jamais mes dialogues et
démocratie directe comme nous le faisons
marine le fera demain à l'échelle du
pays et avec le référendum nous
rétablirons la confiance et le respect
de tous nos engagements
non mesdames et messieurs la victoire
n'est pas possible elle est impérative à
pour nous a pour nous pas pour la france
mais pour les français qui doutent de
plus en plus des politiques de leur
façon de se partager les places en
mettant tout le monde dans des casses
blanc bonnet et bonnet blanc disait jean
marie le pen il y a déjà un certain
nombre d'années eh bien il avait raison
eh bien il avait raison
ce n'est plus
ce n'est plus la bande des quatre qui
nous dirigent aujourd'hui c'est le tous
contre marine pourquoi pourquoi se pose
et y avait tant de force car dans cette
campagne elle est bien la seule à
défendre les citoyens tous les citoyens
leur souveraineté et donc la nation en
avril pour que les français dirige la
france voté marine candidate du peuple
candidate de la nation
merci louis merci de ta détresse c'était
louis aliot qui a pris la parole y aura
bientôt le jour d'anbar leïla est
ensuite marine le pen pour ce discours
tant attendu on a une petite question
dans le chatt là qui vient d'arriver qui
nous disait eric zemmour avec marine le
pen est ce qu'une alliance serait
possible envisageable 1% de chance au
deuxième tour qu'est ce qu'on peut dire
pour l'instant ça me semble totalement
inenvisageable
les deux se sont lancés sur sur des
rails qui sont parallèles mais après
peut-être que si les intentions de vote
de l'un ou de l'autre deviennent
particulièrement faible s'effondre pour
le dire clairement peut-être que cela
contraindrait l'un des deux à rejoindre
l'autre mais pour l'instant c'est
vraiment un scénario très hypothétique
c'est en plus c'est toujours très
compliqué de faire campagne puisque la
zemmour et marine le pen faut quand même
campagne un peu l'un contre l'autre de
de se rassembler à la fin ça
montre une certaine
c'est pas authentique oui c'est pas
authentique et puis plus on approche du
scrutin plus c'est compliqué on se
rappelle qu'en
2016 à l'automne 2016 françois bayrou
avait lancé quelques piques à ses
virulentes à emmanuel macron parce
qu'évidemment il était sur le même
positionnement
politique sur le même espace électoral
donc le françois bayrou cherché à
défendre son capital électoral mais ça
c'était c'était à l'automne et son
ralliement date du mois de février il ya
eu il ya eu un cheminement ça c'est pas
ça ne se fait pas instantanément passé
par effectivement que vous le dites une
opposition
électorale franche un ralliement
immédiat effectivement je voulais vous
interroger sur cette question n'a pas eu
peur de la porosité entre les deux
électorats l'arrivée de zemmour est ce
qu'elle a est-ce que ça enlevé 14%
d'intentions de vote à marine le pen ou
est ce que c'est un peu plus compliqué
que ça alors quand on regarde là en fait
on fait dans les intentions de vote
c'est l'un des avantages des sondages
d'intentions de vote ont fait les deux
hypothèses ils ont fait une hypothèse
uniquement marine le pen est une
hypothèse dans laquelle nous testons
marine le pen et eric zemmour pour voir
d'où provient
l'électorat d'eric zemmour ou est-ce
qu'il prend des voix et bien c'est
essentiellement à marine le pen de
mémoire 9 à 10 points qui proviennent de
marine le pen il ya une autre façon de
le mesurer eric zemmour
recueille aujourd'hui 30% des électeurs
de marine le pen de 2017 30% donc c'est
vraiment considérable c'est évidemment
la candidate qui a été le plus pénalisés
par l'irruption de ce candidat parce
qu'anna d'autres un peu haut
on a pu l'identifier en tout cas oui ça
joue aussi un peu sur la candidate des
républicains mais dans une moindre
mesure valérie pécresse aujourd'hui à 16
16% c'est beaucoup plus bas que le score
de françois fillon au premier tour de
2017 qui étaient 20% qui était lui même
un score historiquement bas pour les
républicains auxquels est encore un
petit peu en dessous il ya une partie
des électeurs de françois fillon qui
sont partis chez emmanuel macron
d'ailleurs valérie pécresse se
recueillent aussi le
environ 10% des électeurs de macron de
2010 est donc il ya des transferts dans
les dents les deux tours puis une partie
de ses électeurs de françois fillon qui
ont rejoint eric zemmour mais vraiment
le
le gros des bataillons d'eric zemmour
aujourd'hui ce sont d'anciens électeurs
de marine le pen et du rassemblement
national on vous parlait de valérie
pécresse justement son positionnement
est important pour réussir à garder son
électorat puisqu'elle est un peu serré
les deux côtés par marine le pen les
mondes d'un côté et par emmanuel macron
de l'autre oui ça c'est vraiment tout
l'enjeu c'est d'arriver pour les riz
pécresse un tout l'enjeu c'est arrivé à
élargir son électorat sans faire
l'essuie glace pour reprendre une
expression de son directeur de campagne
donc en fait parvenir à bien arrimer les
électeurs qui sont à sa droite sur les
questions de sécurité et là dans son
dispositif de campagne
c'est le rôle qui est dévolu à eric
ciotti dans une moindre mesure à laurent
wauquiez
bruno retailleau et puis de l'autre côté
tenté de faire revenir tous les
électeurs de droite qui ont rejoint
emmanuel macron les anciens soutiens de
d'alain juppé par exemple ça c'est une
cible électorale qui est importante pour
la candidate des républicains et c'est
peut-être une des clés de à la fois de
son accès au second tour et puis d'une
éventuelle élection effectivement comme
vous le disiez c'est encore très
incertain entre ces trois candidats pour
l'instant dans les intentions de vote
alors que je crois que c'est jordan
bardet la présidente du rap monnaie
nationale qui va me présente du
rationnel par intérim vu que marine le
pen est candidate et lui a laissé la
place finalement qui arrive pour faire
son discours
[Musique]
merci mes amis
64 jours avant le grand rendez vous que
nous a donné l'histoire
soixante quatre jours pour décider du
destin de notre pays la france
soixante quatre jours pour franchir
l'ultime marche qui nous sépare
désormais du pouvoir
jamais jamais dans l'histoire notre
famille politique n'a été si proche de
la victoire
quand nous avons démarré l'ascension de
l'himalaya il y à 49 ans avec un sac de
100 kg sur le dos et des liens aux pieds
personne ne donnait cher de nos chances
de succès on nous a dit vous n'y
arriverez pas cfi su nous allons perdre
et même après 2017 vous êtes finis
passer la main
pourtant aujourd'hui nous poursuivrons
inlassablement l'ascension et lorsque
nous levant la tête nous apercevons la
pas très loin juste au dessus de nous
pressent à portée de main le sommet
glorieux de la victoire
alors que nos idées n'ont jamais été
autant partager plébiscité souvent
copiée nous sommes aujourd'hui en 2022
donné à quelques jours de l'élection
présidentielle dans les intentions de
vote au coude à coude avec emmanuel
macron est donc en capacité de remporter
l'élection présidentielle
[Applaudissements]
alors bien sûr que ce combat est
difficile mes amis mais ce sommet que
nous apercevons nous allons l'atteindre
courir pour y dresser et y planter notre
drapeau tricolore le plus beau drapeau
qui soit au monde celui de la france
millénaire
[Applaudissements]
je vous le dis les derniers mètres
seront ardues et rien ne nous sera
épargné dans cette course à la victoire
le système a des ressources mais je vous
rassure il en a moins que la
détermination qui nous anime et que vous
mettez tous autant que vous êtes partout
dans vos territoires dans cette
magnifique campagne électorale
je rassure également nos adversaires
ainsi que le président de la république
qui n'a pour l'instant pas daigné se
déclarer plus nous seront attaqués plus
nous serons déterminés à marcher vers
l'elysée pour porter nos idées au
pouvoir
vous l'avez vu mes amis et cette journée
vous l'approuvez notre projet et
travaillé réfléchi puissants devant les
chefs d'entreprise comme devant les
policiers il ya quelques jours par des
présentations thématiques que nous en
faisons le sérieux de ces propositions
étonnent par leur pertinence
la stratégie que nous déployons n'est
pas le fruit du hasard mais du savoir
elle n'est pas le fruit de l'ignorance
et de l'expérience en sept années 2000
22 nous vivons un moment de profonds
bouleversements
un bouleversement qui est la réplique
sismique de la précédente élection
présidentielle
en 2017 une première secousse a initié
une grande recomposition du paysage
politique
la précédente élection avait scellé la
disparition du parti socialiste et
l'affaissement des républicains le 10
avril terminera cette oeuvre de
salubrité politique car cette élection
de 2022 va en effet achever le travail
de déblaiement des vieux arbres morts
clivage gauche-droite a vécu mes amis et
ceux qui tentent désespérément de le
ranimer n'ont pas compris qu'un nouveau
monde était en train de naître sous nos
yeux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous mes amis nous avons compris que
face au bloc élitaire incarnée par
monsieur macro et madame pécresse il
nous appartenait de construire et de
conduire le bloc populaire à droite
comme à gauche il existe d'innombrables
france est attachée à l'identité de
notre peuple à la souveraineté de la
france au retour de l'ordre et de
l'autorité à la défense de nos modes de
vie et surtout à l'unité de la nation
dans 2 mois et 5 jours
ce grand mouvement populaire ce
mouvement national et populaire autour
de marine le pen s'imposera et ordonnant
sera toute la vie politique
[Applaudissements]
alors depuis quelques jours on entend
certains parler de l'union des droites
face à une gauche qui seraient 10 ans le
intellectuellement minoritaires je vous
le dis ici c'est s'obstiner dans des
clivages passéiste
c'est refuser de voir que cette gauche
est aujourd'hui en état de mort
cérébrale et peine à franchir les 10 %
d'intentions de vote
[Applaudissements]
4au s'acoquiner avec les islamistes et
les indigéniste qui déboulonne
aujourd'hui nos statuts elle en est
réduite à l'état de groupuscules quant à
valérie pécresse tirez vous en a parlé
cet hidalgo de droite
c'est hidalgo de droite qui se veut plus
macro nist qu emmanuel macron lui-même
la voilà réduite aujourd'hui dans une
bataille de virgule avec le président
macron pour savoir lequel des deux
supprimera le plus de fonctionnaires
alors puisque certains sont tentés par
cette union des droites je vous pose
solennellement la question êtes vous
tentés mes amis par un gouvernement avec
valérie pécresse xavier bertrand ou
renaud muselier
l'union avec cette droite mes amis vous
le savez ne reviendrait qu'à achever
notre nation qu'à la soumettre qu'à la
brader et je dirais halal stomisés nous
savons nous que ce qui va se jouer le 10
avril prochain n'est pas un affrontement
de la droite et de la gauche 10 avril
est un enjeu de civilisation
un enjeu de civilisation qui opposera
les patriotes que nous sommes ceux qui
se soucient au plus profond d'eux mêmes
de la disparition de la france à ceux
qui veulent vivre sur ses ruines et qui
travaillent chaque jour que dieu fait à
la sortir de l'histoire
le 10 avril opposera ceux qui comme nous
modestement se savent infiniment petit à
côté de l'immensité de la france à ceux
qui ont l'arrogance de croire qu'ils
sont plus grands que tout à ses élites
macro nice qui ont bien plus le souci
d'elle même que celui de la france et
des français
10 avril opposera celui qui veut
déconstruire l'histoire de france celui
pour qui la culture français n'existent
pas à ceux qui comme nous
patriotes sommes fiers d'affirmer de
dire d'assumer et de revendiquer que la
france vient de la nuit des temps que
son peuple éternel hélas depuis toujours
et a envie plus que jamais de le rester
pour toujours
[Applaudissements]
comme je lé d'il ya quelques jours à
emmanuel macron devant le parlement
européen de ses promesses d'un monde
nouveau ne restera que ces brimades que
ces humiliations que son cynisme et son
mépris qui auront contribué à rendre le
peuple triste affaiblir sa force vitale
à le faire douter de l'avenir et à le
faire douter de lui-même
alors ici depuis reims mes amis symbole
de la patrie millénaire nous lui disons
monsieur macron pour la france mais
aussi pour l'europe il est vital que
votre mandat reste unique
[Applaudissements]
l'un des symboles d'actualité les plus
forts l'une des meilleures preuves que
ce qui se joue en avril est capitale
pour l'avenir de notre pays et notamment
le harcèlement judiciaire et politique
que je subis depuis quelques jours pour
avoir décrit la ville de trappes en
banlieue parisienne comme étant une
république islamique en miniature
le jour même où une journaliste de m6 et
un habitant de roubaix sont placés sous
protection policière pour avoir décrit
dans un reportage la réalité de cette
ville d'islamiser je suis mis en examen
par la justice de notre pays pour avoir
comparé une ville où un habitant sur
cinq sens et partis combattre en syrie à
une république islamique on marche sur
la tête
attrape désormais comme dans
d'innombrables villes françaises vous
l'avez vu des bars sont obligés
d'arrêter de vendre de l'alcool pour
garder leur clientèle
les boucheries traditionnelles ont
disparu pour laisser place à des
commerces confessionnelles et coiffeurs
sont réservés aux hommes et bien sûr
vous en souvenez les enseignants sont
placés sous protection comme cela avait
été le cas pour didier lemaire
professeur de philosophie qui a été
menacée placé sous protection au mieux
quand ils ne sont pas décapité par des
djihadistes
ce qui se passe en ce moment même à
roubaix mes amis à trappes à saint denis
là où j'ai grandi comme dans tant
d'autres villes de france je vous le dis
sera notre futur si nous n'agissons pas
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
la démocratie a ses lois mais la
démographie aussi quand après un sondage
65 % des jeunes musulmans considèrent
que les lois de la charia sont
supérieures aux lois de la république il
faut être
il faut être dans ces conditions naïf
pour ne pas voir que la france est
menacée dans ce qu'elle est au plus
profond d'elle-même
les islamistes ont tout à craindre de
notre arrivée au pouvoir et je veux leur
dire quand même temps que nous rendrons
aux français leur fierté nous rendrons
la france invivable pour ceux qui la
détestent et la combattent
[Applaudissements]
vous l'avez compris mes amis notre
projet n'est pas de sauver la droite
mais bien de sauver la france
cet enjeu vous le savez est au coeur de
notre projet depuis toujours et nous
avons aussi le devoir de parler du
quotidien des familles de ces millions
de français dont la vie de tous les
jours est abîmée par la crainte celle de
ne pas réussir à boucler les fins de
mois à joindre les deux bouts celle de
réussir à se chauffer dignement à
remplir son caddie de course où le
réservoir de sa voiture sans avoir à se
priver
[Applaudissements]
les mouvements de rue du quinquennat si
sympathique si authentique si populaire
témoigne de ses préoccupations n'ont pas
essentiel mais vitale et les gilets
jaunes ont eu raison rappelons le de se
battre pour les faire entendre
[Applaudissements]
la question du pouvoir d'achat n'est pas
anodine ou marginales comme le pensent
tous les autres candidats à cette
présidentielle
il s'agit pour beaucoup du reste à vivre
quand ce n'est pas pour certains des
plus fragiles du reste à survivre être
patriote mes amis commence par refuser
d'être plus généreux avec les autres
qu'avec les nôtres
[Applaudissements]
nous pouvons être fiers d'avoir été les
premiers à porter ce sujet dans le débat
présidentiel
continuerons à parler de la vie
quotidienne avec des propositions de bon
sens on vous parlera marine ou rendre
français leur argent et stopper cette
insupportable racket fiscal vous l'avez
vu nous entendons avancé sur nos deux
jambes autre projet pour la france prend
en compte à la fois la fin de la france
d'une part mais aussi la fin du mois
d'autre part nous parlons de
l'ensauvagement criminels qu'installe le
laxisme judiciaire mais aussi de
l'ensauvagement social que prépare la
mondialisation nous parlons de l'état
qu'il nous faut restaurer quand certains
veulent le réduire nous parlons des
protections qu'attendent les français il
ya la france et nous l'aimons plus que
tout mais il ya aussi les français nous
ne les oublions pas ceux d'hier
d'aujourd'hui comme ceux à venir qui à
juste titre attendent beaucoup de nous
[Applaudissements]
aucun d'entre eux ne doit être négligé
oublié et encore moins mépriser vision
nationale que nous proposons aux
pays-bas à l'envers de la loi de la
jungle
nous n'oublierons personne ni les zones
rurales de la diagonale du vide ni les
banlieues livrer aux trafiquants et aux
islamistes ni les villes asphyxiée par
une métropolisation excessive et
déshumanisante nous libérerons les zones
de non-droit des caïds les zones de non
france des islamistes mais nous
libérerons aussi les entrepreneurs des
charges les artisans et les commerçants
de la paperasse et la france de la
dictature technocratique de bruxelles
[Applaudissements]
alors mes amis je vous paie une promesse
claire nous allons remettre la france en
ordre nous allons remettre la france en
nombre au nom du peuple et les premiers
bénéficiaires en seront exclusivement
les français
[Applaudissements]
le 10 avril sera un clivage entre les
locales est que nous sommes et les
globalistes que représente monsieur
macron entre les partisans de la
protection et les tenants de la
dérégulation général entre ceux qui sont
de quelque part et veulent le rester et
ceux qui sont de nulle part et plus
fondamentalement entre ceux qui croient
en la france et ceux qui n'y croient
plus nous voulons redonner aux français
le droit d'aimer leur pays oui mes amis
vous avez le droit d'aimer votre pays et
surtout vous avez le droit de le dire de
le revendiquer et de le montrer
[Applaudissements]
à
oh
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
le seul problème c'est que j'avais pas
terminer
mes amis nous voulons redonner aux
français la fierté de ce qu'ils sont et
la fierté de leur histoire nous ne
voulons pas seulement parler aux morts
mais aussi aux vivants nous ne voulons
pas seulement cultiver la nostalgie du
passé mais diffuser cette passion de
l'avenir qui nous anime nous ne voulons
pas condamner les français à se dire que
c'était mieux avant mais leur redonner
avant tout l'espoir de croire que ce
sera mieux demain
[Applaudissements]
le patriotisme est probablement l'idée
la plus moderne qui soit l'idée la plus
ancrée dans le 21e siècle qui vient ne
croyez vous pas que les états unis la
chine la russie le brésil l'inde que
toutes ces puissances ne font pas le
choix de défendre leurs intérêts d'abord
et devra indiquer fièrement leur patrie
et c'est parce que nous voulons rendre
aux français à leur fierté que nous
sommes les seuls à pouvoir faire entrer
la france dans le troisième millénaire
contrairement emmanuel macro qui conçoit
notre pays comme une salle de marché où
l'on joue au casino avec l'argent des
français
comme une province de la commission
européenne nous croyons nous que la
france n'est elle même qu'au premier
rang de l'histoire et dans la grandeur
viser haut et se tenir droit écrivez à
le général de gaulle
cette passion de l'avenir solidement
ancrée dans nos racines cet amour de la
france marine les porte en elle alors
que beaucoup ont sacrifié la france pour
défendre leur poste ou leur carrière
elle aura elle sacrifier sa vie pour
défendre les français
[Applaudissements]
vous savez parce que vous la connaissez
depuis tenté tant d'années qu'elle ne
reculera pas qu'elle ne pliera pas
qu'elle ne retrouvent leurs appâts et
surtout et surtout qu'elle ne vous
trahira pas
[Applaudissements]
les sacrifices personnels qui l attend
durée les épreuves personnelles qu'elle
a su remonter dès l'enfance comme
l'attentât de la ville la poirier et
tourmente qu'elle a traversés et
trahisons qu'elle a essuyé ont fait
d'elle une femme de combat ses qualités
propres sa vision haute son expérience
politique et international en fonte
évidemment une femme d'état et parce que
le moment est venu
nous voulons dire aussi aux français
elise est une femme
[Applaudissements]
alors mes amis et jean conclurait il
nous reste soixante quatre jours pour
tout donner
soixante-quatre jours nous allons
marcher déterminer sur des forces du
grand mouvement populaire qui nous porte
et rien ne doit être négligé la
recherche de parrainages qui doit encore
vous mobiliser les actions de terrain
les meetings les distributions de tracts
la rencontre avec les français la
mobilisation sur les réseaux sociaux la
surveillance des bureaux de vote le jour
du scrutin
la conquête du pouvoir par le peuple
français n'est pas un long fleuve
tranquille
et les militants que vous êtes les plus
expérimentés de la cause nationale
savent que rien qu absolument rien ne
nous sera épargné
que les coups bas les trahisons font
partie des péripéties de campagne mais
les destins individuels et les destins
de carrière sont microscopiques à côté
de la montagne que nous sommes en train
de gravir
[Applaudissements]
les amis vous ne devez pas regarder
cette élection présidentielle mais la
refaire
lorsque c'est le sort du pays qui est en
jeu lorsqu'une course de vitesse et
d'enghien est engagé avec les forces de
déconstruction lorsque nous voyons
apparaître la menace d'une submersion
lorsque notre échec ferait atteindre des
points de non retour il n'y a pas
d'autre option que la victoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai aucun doute
je n'ai aucun doute mes amis
je n'ai aucun doute car nous allons à la
victoire et cette victoire sera d'autant
plus belle d'autant plus éclatante que
nous aurons été la chercher contre vents
et marées contre tout un système ligués
contre nous et contre des adversités des
plus redoutables la campagne que nous
menons sera et je pèse mes mots un des
moments les plus exaltants de votre vie
tous ceux qui la vivrons tous ceux qui
la vivrons florent du temps qui vient du
temps dont on se souvient et vous
pourrez dire
et vous pourrez dire mes amis fièrement
et dans les yeux à ceux que vous aimez
j'y étais j'y étais
[Applaudissements]
mes amis nous allons rendre aux français
leur pays et à notre pays sa grandeur
nous allons rendre français la fierté de
ce qu'ils sont et à notre peuple son
destin c'est à partir d'aujourd'hui
ici à reims que tout commence c'est ici
que nous affirmons haut et fort que nous
n'avons pas encore fini d'être français
vive le peuple français vive la
république et vive la france
merci à vous et bonne campagne dernière
prise de parole avant celle de marine le
pen jordan bardella qui s'est exprimée
président du rassemblement national
par intérim puisque marine le pen lui a
laissé la place en attendant marine le
pen ne devrait pas tarder à arriver nous
voyons là sur les images ça ne devrait
pas tarder à arriver juste une petite
question jordan bardella c'était
beaucoup macron mais jamais mais jamais
ses mots en fête est ce que c'est une
stratégie pour se mettre au dessus de la
mêlée face à ces mots oui absolument
c'est vraiment la stratégie essayer de
recréer le duel macron le pen et de
faire oublier la concurrence d'eric
zemmour ça c'est vraiment très clair il
faut pour la candidate se mettre au même
niveau que le chef de l'état et donc
essayer de renouveler la fiche de 2017
alors que le clip de campagne est en
train de passer en ce moment même sur
les écrans de duras effectivement
puisque la hausse parce le meeting s'est
un peu traditionnelle dernière prise de
parole clip de campagne est arrivé du
candidat qui font la foule voilà oui ça
normalement c'est vraiment là le déroulé
très classique on doit voir normalement
le candidat ou la candidate
arrivée être entravé dans sa progression
par les militants très enthousiaste et
puis finalement parvenir à arriver sur
scène et sous les acclamations ça c'est
la figure imposée de tous les débuts de
deux meetings et de grands discours on
avait vu d'ailleurs exe moore à
villepinte ce candidat qui fend la foule
est effectivement l'enjeu est aussi de
créer lors de ses meetings des belles
images à pouvoir utiliser plus tard à
pour montrer sa dynamique oui pour
montrer ces dynamiques pour créer un
effet de puissance pour créer un effet
de masse et puis surtout pour faire
passer une énergie une campagne
électorale s'est entraîné les les
électeurs donc il faut produire un
sentiment de dynamisme de dynamisme
positif aussi on l'a bien vu dans dans
le discours de jordan bardella à l'idée
de parler de l'avenir campagne
électorale c'est surtout un projet c'est
surtout demain évidemment faux un récit
vous s'appuyer sur un récit de la france
mais c'est d'abord parlé de de demain
avec enthousiasme et avec énergie on va
laisser les images maintenant avec
marine le pen qui devrait arriver d'ici
quelques instants sur le sur la scène
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs chers amis
vous y êtes rassemblés ici arar
berceau de notre histoire millénaire et
vous il nous suivait dans toute la
france et que je salue nous avons un
point commun
un sentiment profond qui nous anime qui
habitent nos réflexions
qui détermine nos soir un sentiment qui
disent aussi nos actions qui fait que
nous sommes ici réunis dans cette ville
où est née la france
ce point commun c'est l'amour de la
patrie l'amour sacré de la patrie
c'est à vous
dans le pote verlaine disait qu'il était
le premier amour l'amour de nos familles
des nôtres ceux d'hier d'aujourd'hui et
de demain
cet attachement à nos paysages à notre
art de vivre à la française à notre
langue si subtile assez courtoisie si
particulière si légendaire qui fait de
la france le plus beau pays du monde
ce pays je le dis avec perte et celle
non
notre pays est un joyau 6 et paraît
inépuisable
générations qui se sont succédé tout au
long des siècles
qu'ils ont travaillé de leurs mains
henri feeder intelligence et par leur
incomparable talent créatif en ont fait
un trésor sans égal
notre pays est l'une des plus vieilles
nations du monde
l'oeuvre d'une histoire de courage
davanture d'audace de grandeur
d'obstacles aussi que l'on aurait pu
croire insurmontable de guerre que l'on
croyait perdus mais toujours toujours de
sursaut glorieux héroïque qui ont permis
à la france de continuer à avancer à
croître en puissance et en sagesse
notre pays
c'est une terre pétri
de sang et de l'âme
se met de la graine qui donne la moisson
parsemé de ces merveilles
architecturales qui sont un hommage au
génie des hommes et aux défis du temps
notre pays ce sont ces villes et
villages si extraordinaire d'harmonie et
de délicatesse
ce sont ces paysages si divers c'est
époustouflant
qui ravissent la vue du promeneur
aspirent les pinces émeuvent les poètes
notre pays ce sont ces plug majestueux
qui descendent des montagnes et
sillonnent nos plaines à la recherche du
grand large
notre pays et je vois nos amis du creux
vers ce sont aussi ces plages lumineuse
essais mer à perte de vue qui ouvre la
prend sur le vaste monde vernon
outre-mer à ses autres terres
[Applaudissements]
pourtant
pourtant ce pays dont nous sommes si
follement amoureux
dont nous sommes si fiers semblent nous
échapper comme si au seuil de ce
millénaire ils étaient entraînés dans le
gigantesque tourbillon du monde dans la
tourmente des événements dans la grande
lessiveuse d'un nouveau siècle qui
semble échapper aux européens
tout se passe comme si nous qui avons
découvert le monde n'avons et pire et de
lumière la bombe grandi de nos valeurs
n'étions plus capables de le comprendre
de l'accompagner et d'y prendre notre
juste place
ce que nous vivons c'est une véritable
dépossession
nous ne reconnaissons plus le pays que
nous aimons
bousculés à l'intérieur humilié à
l'extérieur la france dégringole dans le
classement des puissances un publi par
les erreurs la vanité et le cynisme des
manuels macron
[Applaudissements]
n'oubliez jamais que c'est emmanuel
macron le prétendu mozart de la finance
qui n'a réussi en cinq ans qu'à composer
une symphonie dramatique
son quinquennat se conclut par une dette
augmenter de 600 milliards d'euros et un
commerce extérieur au déficit
vertigineux
avec emmanuel macron on nous avait
promis un crack mais le sol craque que
nous avons vu est financier
alors mes amis
n'oubliez jamais que cette emmanuel
macron qui a bradé nos fleurons qui
faisait de nous une grande nation
industrielle
technique n'a par alcatel est le plus
emblématique de ces dépeçage 7 alstom
dans un pack de trahison quand on ne
parle qu'à me voir dans les milieux
autorisés
n'oubliez jamais que cette emmanuel
macron avec ses contradictions sur le
nucléaire et le sabotage d'edf qui
détruit notre filière énergétique
entraînant perte d'indépendance et
explosion des factures d'électricité
alors
alors qu'on avait l'énergie la plus
décarbonés du monde nous voilà obligés
de réouvrir des centrales à charbon ou
de parler de délestage c'est-à-dire de
coupures de courant en effet quel
progrès
et je ne parle pas du saccage de nos
paysages et de nos côtes avec des
éoliennes anti écologique aux coûts
exorbitants
n'oubliez jamais que c'est emmanuel
macron qui a augmenté les taxes sur le
carburant est spolié les retraités
provoquant le grand mouvement populaire
des gilet jaune n'oubliez jamais que
c'est emmanuel macron qui prétendait
qu'il suffisait de traverser la route
pour trouver un emploi
alors
que le chômage toutes catégories
confondues est au même niveau
aujourd'hui que lorsqu'il a été
n'oubliez jamais que cette emmanuel
macron qui a laissé les blacks blocs ces
milices d'extrême gauche
discréditer toutes les protestations
sociales dans un déchaînement de
violence
n'oubliez jamais que c'est emmanuel
macron qu'à stigmatiser puis insulté les
français n'ont vacciné pour faire
oublier sa gestion catastrophique de
l'épidémie
personne ne doit être qu
le progressisme d'emmanuel macron ne
signifie pas progrès mais des
constructions pas à avancer mais
régression
c'est lui
celui qui clamait que la culture
française n'existait pas les sans réagir
et parfois en les accompagnant les
idéologies destructrices ronger les
fondations de l'harmonie sociale le moc
isme la repentance le racialisme
l'indigénisme le des colonialismes tout
semble le porter à un saccage méthodique
de ce qui fait la france
son quinquennat fut un immense chaos
avec des crises à répétition qu emmanuel
macron a provoqué et l'anc retenu
notre société mes chers amis se trouvent
fracturé comme jamais multi fracturé
même fracture territoriale fracture
sociale fracture culturelle fracture
générationnelle en clair une france
polytraumatisé
ce qui domine sourdement dans le coeur
des français c'est un sentiment
d'abandon
abandon des classes populaires et des
classes moyennes
abandon des jeunes et des plus âgés
abandon des campagnes comme des
outre-mer ce sentiment d'abandon
fragilise notre pays de l'intérieur
à chacun de mes déplacements dans nos
territoires à chacune de mes rencontres
avec les français je sens s'est fracturé
s'aggraver sous le coup du maquereau
nisme synthèse terrible du cynisme et de
l'injustice
la france est plongée dans une morosité
qui ne lui ressemble pas dans une sorte
de grande dépression sociale et
psychologique
emmanuel macron n'est pas seulement mes
prisons il est déprimant
[Applaudissements]
alors mes z'amis
ce sentiment je le comprends
ce sentiment je pourrais le partager
mais pourtant nous devons le combattre
de toute notre âme et de toutes nos
forces
la lassitude la tristesse la peur
l'angoissé sont tout autant d'armes
utilisées par ceux qui nous gouvernent
si mal pour nous faire oublier que le
bonheur la prospérité la sécurité sont à
portée de main je dirais même apporté de
vote
le maquereau nisme est une machine à
broyer les espoirs sous couvert de
progressisme
c'est l'avènement d'une société sans
lien sans solidarité sociale ou
familiale
celle de l'individu tout puissant mais
seuls
n'écoutez plus les mauvaises oiseaux
d'eau pure qui matin midi et soir vous
répète que la france est finie que nous
sommes un petit pays avec un petit
peuple ces agents de malheur ne vous
disent pas la vérité il vous empoisonne
la mme labelle et ardente am française à
laquelle je veux faire appel pour
relever notre pays je sais au plus
profond de moi-même kunié rassembler les
français peuvent réussir l'impossible
ma première mission comme candidat à la
présidence de la république est donc
clair briser le cycle infernal du
défaitisme
la france
vous n'êtes pas condamné au déclin les
français ne sont pas condamnés à
l'abandon ensemble nous allons rendre à
nos compatriotes la france qu'ils aiment
[Applaudissements]
et nos pays qu'ils aiment c'est avant
tout une nation et lui vend sécurité
l'ensauvagement sans qui ce partout
non
[Musique]
mes chers amis
profitez-en avec les islamistes
nous ne verrons probablement plus jamais
de femme nue
[Applaudissements]
le pays qu'ils aiment vous disais c'est
avant tout une nation où ils vivent en
sécurité
l'ensauvagement s'enkystent partout dans
les petites villes dans les bourgs dans
les zones rurales les plus reculées dans
les transports à l'école à l'hôpital et
parfois même dans les familles
c'est dans ce bâtiment atteint partout
un niveau tel qu'il commence à empêcher
toute vie sociale contrarie la vie
économique aegas même les joies les plus
simples de la vie la france orange ma
chronique
[Applaudissements]
il ya une coccinelle sur mon pupitre est
ce que vous croyez que ça porte chance
[Applaudissements]
je vous en parlais tout à l'heure
mais les femmes et les jeunes filles
craignent aujourd'hui l'espace public
devenu dans certaines villes un lieu de
harcèlement permanent
les honnêtes gens subissent en silence
sa sereine ya des stratégies d'évitement
permanent ces stratégies nous les
connaissons tous nous les époux vont
chaque jour avec silence et dignité
je serai la présidente qui rendra sa
sécurité à la france 5 qui rendra en
français ce droit inné la nina d'alain
sûreté
[Applaudissements]
n'en déplaise à monsieur dupont moretti
je préférerai toujours les victimes au
delà quand les policiers aux criminels
la vraie solution à la demande et
station la rapidité de la condamnation à
l'enlisement judiciaire un seul mot dans
une ligne claire la certitude de la
peine le soutien indéfectible aux forces
de l'ordre et l'augmentation massive des
moyens de la justice
jamais ma main ne tremblera
lorsqu'il s'agira de défendre les
français et ceux qui les protège
ma main ne tremblera pas plus lorsqu'il
s'agira de protéger les français contre
la submersion migratoire
je les dis
je les dis et vous le constater
quotidiennement il y a un lien évident
entre l'explosion de l'insécurité et ses
vagues d'immigration que nous subissons
mais pas seulement
qui peut également nier l'impact de
l'immigration sur nos services publics
la saturation de nos hôpitaux le manque
de logements sociaux et l'engorgement de
notre système judiciaire
penser que 60% du travail des magistrats
administratifs
concerne les étrangers
par vague continue cette immigration
hors contrôle transforme nos rues nos
quartiers nos villes en zone de non
france
elle installe chez nous des modes de vie
qui ne sont pas les nôtres
elle exige des accommodements qui sont
en réalité pour nous français la marque
d'un reniement culturel elle se traduit
par des revendications communautaristes
à ses sens souvent incompatibles avec ce
que nous sommes
l institut à séparatisme insidieux qui
finit toujours par devenir belliqueux
celle arrogant et sulfureux maire de
trappes qui vit à jordan
qui dit cette société multiculturelle
elle adviendra de gré ou de force
de force
mais quel amoureux
avec saint-orens et le communautarisme
qui s'installe et qui fait le lit de
l'islamisme
avec l'islamisme ce sont nos valeurs les
plus essentielles qui sont emportés la
laïcité la mixité et l'égalité hommes
femmes la liberté d'expression avec le
retour du délit de blasphème la liberté
de croire ou de ne pas croire la liberté
d'enseigner ou d'informer c'est cet
islamisme qui conduit à des assassinats
à crosse comme celui de samuel pâti des
persécutions comme celle subie par milla
ou des menaces infamante comme celle
subie par ophélie meunier
penser
penser que dans la france de 2022 les
pouvoirs publics doivent aujourd'hui
dans notre pays
légiférer contre l'excision ou contre
les certificat de virginité
mais où va t'on
jamais la femme que je suis né en
1968 aurait pu imaginer que nous en
arrivions là
malgré
malgré nos mises en garde et alertent
depuis des années
emmanuel macron s'en est tenu à des
discours à des postures et même à des
compromissions temps sur l'islamisme que
sur l'immigration pire au lieu d'arrêter
l'immigration il aggrave chaque jour
davantage
cohérent il s'apprête à faire subir
alors le même traitement le même mauvais
traitements migratoires c'est le fameux
pacte des migrations
pacte avec le diable dans les
conséquences juridiques seront terribles
pour notre pays
ce pacte prévoit tenez vous bien de
transférer définitivement à l'union
européenne le pouvoir de dire qui a le
droit de s'installer chez nous et qui
doit partir
[Musique]
vous me direz la manade emmanuel macron
est limpide pour supprimer l'immigration
illégale il suffit de la rendre légale
imaginer qu'avec ce pacte des migrations
coercitif les pays européens devront
obligatoirement admettre les migrants
recueillis en mer mais il faut
s'attendre à des dizaines d'aquarius
formant un pont maritime avec l'afrique
moi je vous le dis avec force
cette aux français de décider qui
peuplent la france
c'est aux français de dire qui peut
devenir princesse
[Applaudissements]
et dès mon élection c'est par référendum
qu ils le diront je rendrai aux français
leur pays
car mes amis
cette immigration est une immigration de
peuplement
avec des gens qu'ils vivront chez nous
comme ils vivent chez eux
cette immigration sera irréversible
c'est une politique voulue une politique
mise en oeuvre quoi qu'il en coûte sans
aucune évaluation ni financière ni
sociale ni humaine
courageux
ils mettront en place ce pacte je cite
après les élections françaises
bon vous me direz certains y verront un
hommage direct aux gaulois réfractaires
dont la docilité fait trembler les
commissaires grisâtre de bruxelles
j'y vois
[Applaudissements]
j voi chers compatriotes et même cher
patriote un appel à la mobilisation
nous sommes les seuls à pouvoir sauver
la france et l'europe par notre vote des
tice et 24 avril
[Applaudissements]
les dirigeants européens donc vous avez
vu les vidéos
ne vous ont pas dit autre chose
l'europe entière nous regarde et nous a
tant par un référendum qui ne souffrira
aucune contestation de légitimité des
français adopteront au lendemain de mon
élection un plan global juridiquement
applicable une solution clé en main
contre l'immigration voté pour nous on
s'occupe de tout
[Applaudissements]
ma politique en matière d'immigration
tiendra en trois principes 1 la france
restera maîtresse de sa politique
migratoire
2 les étrangers qui veulent venir
devront subvenir à leurs besoins
3 c'est nous qui décidons qui peut
rester ou qui doit partir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
mes amis
new roman
nous rendrons à valeur à la nationalité
française
danton n'hérite ou que l'on mérite
les abus du droit d'asile seront stoppés
aucun corps destin ne sera plus
régulariser ni même régularisables
le comprend les pompes aspirantes en
réservant certaines aides sociales aux
français en instaurant la priorité
nationale au logement et à l'emploi
le communautarisme
le communautarisme sera prohibée quant à
l'idéologie islamiste totalitaire et
meurtrière ennemis de la france elle
sera combattue par tous ces
représentation légale interdite et ses
promoteurs condamner et à chaque fois
que ce sera possible
expulsé manu militari
[Applaudissements]
j'allais vous le dire
la laïcité sera appliquée notamment dans
l'espace public les administrations et
les entreprises
rendre son identité sa fierté à la
france pour le dire clairement les
français seront de nouveaux maîtres chez
eux
nous sommes confrontés à deux visions de
l'homme et du monde et elle conditionne
l'avenir de nos pays c'est le sens du
clivage dont jordan parlais tout à
l'heure entre nationaux et mondialiste
entre localités globaliste entre nous
partisan de la protection et e partisan
de la déréglementation généralisée
pour nous notre pays passe avant tout
nos familles passent avant tout notre
peuple passe avant tout
mais
les amis protéger notre peuple c'est
aussi assurer à tous les français de
vivre dignement
vous savez l'accord l'importance que
j'accorde à votre pouvoir d'achat mon
engagement est clair c'est celui de
rendre en moyenne 200 euros par mois à
tous les ménages français
la mesure la plus emblématique sera la
baisse de la tva de 20% à 5 5% sur
l'électricité le gaz le fioul et le
carburant
l'énergie est un bien de première
nécessité
ce soap et se déplacer aller travailler
mais qui peut s'en passer
ce sont 12 milliards qui vous seront
rendus et je ne me contenterai pas de
rendre leur argent aux français j'agirai
aussi sur les salaires trop bas depuis
trop longtemps
je permettrai dans un engagement commun
avec les entreprises une hausse de 10%
jusqu'à 3 fois le smic en dispensant les
entreprises de charges sur ces
augmentations
l'appauvrissement des français n'est pas
une fatalité et dans deux mois je vous
le trouverez
[Applaudissements]
mais je vous prouvera est également que
nous pouvons retrouver un système de
santé performant celui vous souvenez qui
faisait hier la fierté de notre pays
des tensions hospitalières lors de la
crise du coc vide les déserts médicaux
la faillite des ars l'épuisement moral
et physique des personnages hospitalier
tout montre que notre système de soins a
été saccagé par les gouvernements
successifs et qu'il faut faire de sa
restauration une des priorités de mon
quinquennat
moratoire sur la fermeture de lits
moyens budgétaires accrus
débureaucratisation
fluidification des urgences par la
création d' urgences gériatriques pour
ne plus voir ces images insoutenables de
nos personnes âgées attendant pendant
des heures dans des couloirs
incitations à l'installation de jeunes
médecins ou à la création de maisons de
santé
revalorisation des salaires des
soignants sous payés par rapport à la
moyenne européenne
réintégration des personnels injustement
suspendu
et puis enfin de l'opposition stérile
entre médecine publique et privée je
rendrai un système de santé solide et
performant aux français parce que pardon
mais
applaudir les soignants c'est bien mais
les contraindre comme la paix le
gouvernement d' emmanuel macron à
travailler dans des conditions aussi
dégradée ça n'est plus possible
ça n'est plus possible
né à l'hôpital né dans les ehpad
donner aux soignants les moyens de leur
mission est donc vital je ne ferai pas
la présidente qui fermera les yeux sur
la situation intolérable de nos aînés
dans certains ehpad
mais je serai celle qui leur assurera
respect et dignité
celle qui garantira aux familles un
droit de visite en toute circonstance
pour que plus jamais les plus
vulnérables ne soit condamné l isolement
la grandeur de notre société se mesure à
l'attention que nous portons à l'égard
des plus vulnérables
parmi les plus vulnérables
je pense bien évidemment aux personnes
touchées par le handicap et à leurs
familles
la france a su par le passé mettre en
place de grandes politiques afin
d'assurer aux handicapés leur juste
place dans la société
ma première mesure sera 2d conjugue
alizés et d'augmenter l'allocation
adultes handicapés jusqu'à 1000 euros
mesure que j'ai soutenu
sur les bancs de l'assemblée nationale
passe au gouvernement d' emmanuel macron
qui restait sourd à cette exigence
minimale de justice
l'inclusion des enfants porteurs de
handicap dans nos écoles est l'une des
plus belles réussites françaises
mais oui c'est dès le plus jeune âge
que ces enfants doivent vivre avec leurs
camarades bien sûr pour ceux hélas qui
ont besoin de plus d'attention et de
soins des établissements spécialisés
sont ouverts en nombre pour leur
permettre de poursuivre des études
adapté et en vertu de la même
philosophie
les aidants
les aidants dont le don de soi la
générosité
l'abnégation force le respect
ces aidants qui viennent au sommet des
personnes âgées parfois au chevet des
personnes en fin de vie ou des personnes
handicapées il faut les indemnisés en
fonction de leurs pertes salariales il
faut leur portée leur congé dédain de
trois mois à 12 mois
dans un monde mais chers amis où l'on
veut
dans un monde où on veut que tout se
monnaie
que tout soit mesurée à l'aune de
l'argent roi
c'est française et ces français qui
porte les valeurs de solidarité doivent
être soutenus et ils doivent être aussi
remercier
[Musique]
voilà
protéger les français c'est aussi mettre
fin au pillage de la france en luttant
contre la fraude enfin pardon les
fraudes
président de la république je ne
laisserai plus les français être volés
par ceux qui depuis tant d'années
détourne la prospérité collective en
toute impunité
la fraude c'est du vol est un vol par
dizaines de milliards d'euros
fraude aux prestations sociales aux
cotisations sociales n'est pas seulement
les ententes la fraude les fraudes un
étiquetage les fraudes aux importations
sans oublier l'évasion fiscale alors un
mini serre sera spécialement dédié
à s'occuper des fraudeurs
qui font leur fortune sur le dos des
contribuables ou d'ailleurs des
consommateurs
on commencera avec la carte vitale
biométrique
et je pense qu'on va avoir de sacrées
surprises
alors ce ministère eh bien il sera
chargé de récupérer les ressources qui
ont par ailleurs tant manqué à nos
services publics et en particulier à
l'hôpital
enfin comment parler de protection sans
évoquer celle de notre territoire
national alors des grandes menaces et
des grands bouleversements stratégiques
la france ne serait pas elle même si
elle ne paie pas pour une politique de
pleine indépendance
nous devons défendre librement nos
intérêts sortir de la logique belliciste
des blocs pour renouer avec la stratégie
d' équilibre qui a fait je vous le
rappelle la grandeur de notre pays
c'est pourquoi nous sortirons du
commandement intégré de l'otan afin de
ne plus être entraîné dans des conflits
qui ne sont pas les nôtres
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'impression d'ouvrir une porte
ouverte mais je vous assure qu' il faut
le redire la défense de notre patrie et
de nos intérêts vitaux ne peut pas être
déléguée elle ne peut être confiée qu'à
une armée nationale
renforcée dans ses moyens soutenu dans
ses missions consolidé par la cohérence
des alliances elle demeurera n'en
déplaise aux verts appuyez sur la
dissuasion nucléaire
protection ultime de la france qui par
voie de conséquence restera sous son
autorité exclusive
protéger
la france pourra ainsi retrouver sa
place si particulière dans le concert
des nations
dans ce monde qui s'invente de nouvelle
guerre froide et doit faire entendre une
voix forte et indépendante en usant
notamment le son siège diplomatique au
conseil de sécurité
ce privilège diplomatique legs du
général de gaulle nous ne le partageront
avec personne
personne
ni avec l'allemagne ni avec quiconque
et puis nous reviendrons à des relations
bilatérales notamment avec les pays amis
d'afrique souvent lié à la france par
l'histoire par l'affection mutuel et la
francophonie
le monde non alignés à temps la france
nous serons au rendez vous en europe
nous réformerons l'union européenne pour
lui substituer une alliance européenne
des nations son fonctionnement sera au
rendez vous le savez sur la souveraineté
des peuples on ne veut plus admettre que
des pays qui souhaitent rester
souverains comme la pologne ou la
hongrie soit menacée de sanctions
financières incroyablement lourde pour
avoir seulement voulu faire respecter la
volonté de leur peuple et bien moi
je vous dis aujourd'hui
honneur à eux et honte à bruxelles
[Applaudissements]
notre outre-mer
ah oui
voilà un beau slogan
oh
notre au travers si chère à mon coeur
vous le savez sera au centre de cette
politique de projection l'espace
maritime qu'elle offre à la france sera
demain un grand projet national comme le
fut la conquête de l'espace nous allons
nous appuyons sur la vitalité de nos
compatriotes d'outre-mer partir à la
conquête de nos mères et de leurs
incroyables ressources en respectant
bien sûr la merveilleuse biodiversité
qu'elle nous offre l'or bleu l'or bleu
participera à l'essor de tous nos
territoires ultramarins et par voie de
conséquence à tous notre pays voyez ce
grand projet illustre parfaitement la
politique économique que nous souhaitons
fondée sur un état stratège c'est à dire
un état qui crée un environnement
économique favorable et qui garantisse à
tous et notamment aux indépendants aux
petits entrepreneurs aux pme une juste
et saine concurrence la sécurité
juridique et la désinflation des normes
nous reprendrons le système économique
en l'appuyant sur deux piliers le
localisme le patriotisme économique
cette croissance
elle sera soutenue par un fonds
souverain puissant et patriote
ce fonds souverain en réalité il sera
abondé contre rémunération comme le
livret à part les pagnes de par
l'épargné des français qui le souhaitent
se font souvent il permettra la
réalisation d'infrastructures d'avenir
dont nous avons tant besoin
la transformation environnementale et
énergétique la recherche l'innovation
mais aussi la relocalisation
industrielle
nous le savons rien n'est possible sans
les entreprises et notamment les très
petites entreprises les petites et
moyennes entreprises qui sont souvent
moins bien traités que les grands
groupes alors qu'elles sont le coeur de
notre économie c'est pourquoi
je le dédie
mon ben ali n'est clair tout pour les
tpe pme ça veut dire quoi mais ça veut
dire que nous les nous les font
bénéficier prioritairement des
allègements d'impôts de production en
supprimant ce qui pèse plus
spécifiquement sur aisne notamment la
cfe
nous avons confiance dans nos petites et
moyennes entreprises mais il est temps
qu'elle le voit nous avons besoin
qu'elle s'installe dans la ruralité
qu'elle crée des emplois pour vous et
vos enfants nous les y aiderons nous
remettrons à l'honneur l'excellence du
fabriqué en france et protégeront les
artisans leur savoir-faire leur talent
créatif et cette conscience du travail
bien fait qui sont un élément du génie
français
nous redonnerons au travail sa noblesse
et sa valeur et comment parler de
noblesse et de valeur du travail sans
parler de nos agriculteurs
l'agriculture notre agriculture doit
redevenir l'instrument de l'excellence
française au service de la souveraineté
alimentaire de notre pays le modèle
d'agriculture familiale doit être
protégé de la prédation bancaire de la
concurrence déloyale de normes du yo-yo
des cours de l'avidité de la grande
distribution
des pièces de la transmission
d'entreprises mais aussi des campagnes
de diffamation et d'agression organisé
par les talibans de la verdure
[Applaudissements]
la qualité des produits agricoles doit
être reconnu les agriculteurs protéger
leurs revenus sécurisés et la première
preuve de confiance sera de rendre
obligatoire à terme l'utilisation des
produits français dans nos cantines
[Applaudissements]
la france de demain devrait être un
territoire rééquilibrer au profit des
villes moyennes et de la ruralité sept
grands politiques de justice
territoriale c'est notre fameuse des
métropolisation
lutter contre la fracture territoriale
est une nécessité lutter contre la
fracture sociale est une urgence absolue
la priorité d'un pays qui veut se
projeter dans l'avenir ce sont ces
jeunes à qui nous devons donner les
moyens de leurs rêves
je veux
je veux leur offrir autre chose que la
banque du droit à l'échec de valérie
pécresse
[Applaudissements]
je veux les gardes et les inciter à
rester en france à y étudier avec des
aides accessibles à y travailler à y
produire à y créer des entreprises
allait fonder une famille
c'est pourquoi j'ai pris cet engagement
inédit de supprimer l'impôt sur le
revenu pour tous les moins de 30 ans
je veux également que les étudiants qui
ont un emploi soit récompensé par une
prime afin de leur permettre à tous de
sortir de la précarité
je veux valoriser l'alternance et
l'apprentissage en augmentant de 200
euros par mois les indemnités de ceux
qui font le choix de filières
professionnelles dont nous avons tant
besoin
mes amis
les jeunes doivent faire l'objet de
toute notre attention
il faut leur redonner confiance en vie
joie de vivre ils sont le baromètre de
la vitalité de notre pays nous devons
pouvoir compter sur eux mais ils doivent
aussi pouvoir compter sur nous voyez
dans cette grande politique la confiance
que nous avons dans l'avenir à quoi sert
de protéger en même temps à quoi sert de
se projeter si l'on ne sait pas
transmettre
le premier lieu de la transmission c'est
la famille la famille grand maltraité
des dernier quinquennat
les attaques ininterrompue contre la
famille ont une conséquence dirait les
français sont découragés d'avoir des
enfants
moi je fais le soin des enfants
je veux que la nation n les couples qui
le souhaitent à accueillir cet immense
bonheur qu'elle l'europe des conditions
de vie heureuse qu'elle les protège quel
les entoure
je n'oublierai pas
ces enfants maltraités
que leurs parents n'ont pas su pas pu ou
pas voulu aimer correctement
ces enfants sont dans l'angle mort de la
société
la nation doit à les protéger
ce sont nos enfants ce sont les enfants
de la nation française
il mérite une attention et même une
affection particulière de notre part
[Applaudissements]
attention attention particulière aussi
pour les nombreuses familles françaises
monoparentales
pour lesquelles je doublerai
l'allocation de soutien familial
vous avez
élevé seules des enfants
situation beaucoup plus souvent subie
que choisie est un poids financier et
psychologique lourd la nation se doit de
compenser ses difficultés en aidant les
parents seuls à faire face à ces
obstacles afin que tous les enfants de
france connaissent le bonheur dans notre
beau pays j'aiderai les familles et je
m'appuierai sur l'école qui sera
restaurée dans sa mission de
transmission des savoirs il ne s'agit
pas
il ne s'agit pas de restaurer l'école du
19e siècle mais de donner à tous nos
enfants la base nécessaire à leur future
vie d'adulte
pour cela je ferai du soutien aux
enseignants l'une de mes priorités ce si
beau métier est aujourd'hui délaissée et
donc dégradé outre une revalorisation
significative de la salers ils seront
soutenus par l'état lorsque la violence
de la société viendra troubler ce
sanctuaire que doit rester l'école
confort
enfin la transmission c'est bien sûr le
lien entre générations
pour que ces nuits un perdure je
souhaite supprimer pour l'immense
majorité de nos compatriotes ses impôts
injustes que sont les droits de
succession à 6
ainsi mes amis parce que je crois en
l'enracinement ainsi nos maisons
familiales
qui sont souvent l'écrin de nos
histoires de nos souvenirs de notre
mémoire mais aussi le fruit du travail
de nos parents de nos aïeux ne seront
plus concernés par les droits de
succession de même je souhaite faciliter
les donations entre générations par un
allègement important des impôts pas
seulement entre parents et enfants mais
aussi entre grands parents et petits
enfants pour que
pour que ces liens ne soient pas un
poids pour les plus jeunes je
réintégrerai les retraites sur
l'inflation kirnu sa canne et les
pensions de nos seniors
je fixerai à principe pas une seule
retraite en dessous de 1000 euros
[Applaudissements]
je resterai également la demi part des
veufs et veuves
assez minablement supprimés par françois
hollande
[Musique]
de liens entre générations c'est bien
sûr la transmission de notre culture
ciment de notre nation incarnez dans le
patrimoine national
matériel et immatériel
matérialisé par notre langue notre
culture fait l'objet aujourd'hui de
nombreuses attaques y compris de la part
d' emmanuel macron directement je ferai
de la défense de la langue française une
des priorités de la politique culturelle
en mettant fin cet usage délétère de
l'anglais par nos entreprises nos
administrations et même le gouvernement
et même le président de la république
actuel
[Applaudissements]
l'écriture inclusive sera interdite
bonne nouvelle la carte nationale
d'identité sera à nouveau en français et
seulement en français
vous savez le français est un levier
puissant pour renforcer les liens y
compris économiques avec les pays qui
partagent usage de cette belle langue
prendra peut-être le faire dans le cadre
d'une union francophone pour entretenir
notre patrimoine bâti naturel je mettrai
en place un service national du
patrimoine sur la base du volontariat
parce que nos jeunes pourront ainsi
participer à son entretien et apprendre
à l'aimer voilà mes amis les grandes
lignes de mon projet
il est en totale opposition avec celui
d'emmanuel mc ren et de son clown
valérie pécresse
quand
quand le premier ruine la france la
seconde trompe ses électeurs
si de l'avis de tous nous avons gagné la
bataille du constant et nombre de
candidats y braconne avec des
conversions parfois récente toujours
opportuniste les français nous attendent
sur les solutions
il nous y attendent sans outrance sans
provocation sans blesser sans exciter
les tensions sans rajouter des problèmes
nos problèmes
nous devons clore la parenthèse macron
nous allons l'accord
[Applaudissements]
faites en sorte mes amis que les cinq
prochaines années ce soit sans lui
[Applaudissements]
à
mon projet politique est donnée à la
patrie les moyens de sa grandeur et de
donner aux français les moyens de leur
bonheur au projet de faire entrer la
france dans le troisième millénaire de
lui donner tous les atouts pour
affronter le monde qui vient
vous l'avez compris mon projet travaillé
réfléchi complet il est sifflé
parfaitement équilibré il fixe une
feuille de route précise solide
immédiatement applicables il dessine un
chemin clair de prospérité de sécurité
du cohésion nationale il n'a pas
vocation à être de droite ou de gauche
il s'adresse à tous les français il est
un projet pour la france
une france fière de ses valeurs et de
son histoire une france résolument
tourné vers l'avenir une france qui
croit au travail à l'effort une france
unie à l'intérieur et respecter l
extérieur une france attentive aux
personnes les plus vulnérables
une france bienveillante pour ses
enfants tous ces enfants une france
heureuse une france rayonnante dans le
monde chers compatriotes dans cette
magnifique cité de reims qui fut le
sanctuaire des serments sacré des rois
de france à servir leurs peuples
la france doit se souvenir des promesses
de son baptême
notre nation impact deux fois millénaire
avec la liberté du monde mais aussi avec
l'idéal d'égalité et l'espérance de
fraternité notre devise nationale 10
brand des victoires des hommes et des
femmes sur la fatalité doit être relevée
tel notre drapeau bleu-blanc-rouge mise
à terre par les lâcheté des
gouvernements faillite
[Applaudissements]
ce serment sacré ce pacte millénaire
cette devise nationale voilà le rêve
français qui doit nous animer voilà le
rêve français que nous allons retrouver
fait confiance à cet idéal faites
confiance à vos idéaux ensemble nous
allons rendre notre pain macro skull m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
maintenant
maintenant mes amis je vais prendre
quelques minutes pour vous parler de moi
parce que
je crois que l'élection à la présidence
de la république c'est d'abord une
rencontre entre le peuple et un homme
une femme et en l'occurrence une femme
[Musique]
une président de la république est élu
sur un projet certes je viens de vous le
présenter
sur un positionnement politique vous
savez que le mien est nationale mais je
crois profondément que le tempérament le
parcours la personnalité de celle que
les français choisiront sont
déterminants
ce sont des éléments qui permettront de
savoir comment elle réagira comment l
arbitre a les incalculables décision que
dans ses fonctions chaque jour elle est
amenée à prendre
10 km mais souvient me porte la
politique fait partie de mon existence
a peur pris dans le tourbillon des
engagements que je voyais trop rarement
une famille un peu particulière où les
idées et l'action
le combat politique vite mais la vie
j'ai l'habitude de dire que j'aime ce
cas là des la politique par la face nord
prévu très vite j'ai connu la violence
politique quand j'étais petite fille à
l'école m'a fait payer l'engagement de
mon père des persécutions
que l'esprit d'une enfant insouciante ne
peut pas vraiment comprendre
les persécutions qu'ils me font honnir
aujourd'hui toute idée de discrimination
j'en mesure la justice j'en connais bien
souffrance
oui
et puis il a eu cet
attentat
j'avais 8 ans
le silence d'abord le silence de
l'explosion qui rend sourd puis la fumée
les voix qui appellent vue cloud vers lé
sentiment de n'avoir plus rien
sous nos pieds que mon petit lit
d'enfant en équilibre dans le vide
et puis la question
qui est mort qui est vivant
la famille est sauvé mes soeurs mes
parents mais le petit garçon d'un an de
nos voisins sur le palier en face de
chez nous a été projetée du cinquième
étage
il s'en est sorti avec un bras cassé
il ya ceux qui croient au ciel et ceux
qui n'y croient pas moi j'y crois
c'est la peur
ce matin-là de la toussaint 1976 je suis
entré brutalement dans le monde des
adultes
un monde où l'on sait que tout est
fragile que les méchants existe
cette idée ne m'a jamais quittée et la
vie faut bien dire ne l'a pas démentie
et puis il ya eu ce divorce parental
ultra médiatisé qui
vous prive du droit à la pudeur auquel
on est si attaché quand on a 16 ans
et l'expérience que l'on espère que la
vie en fait est fait de sacrifices de
difficultés des preuves elle nous
instruisent ces épreuves elle vous
construit
la certitude aussi que les gens qui ont
vécu des choses douloureuses perçoit
mieux les blessures les souffrances la
détresse
ces sacrifices que nous consentons me
rappelle cette crête belles phrases
délit de nos apps amar qui est souvent à
supporter les efforts en dur et
si rien est sacrifiée
rien est obtenu
je suis devenu avocat
par passion du juste par souci de
défendre ce qui pouvait l'être par défi
de faire triompher les causes auxquelles
je pouvais croire
et puis je suis devenue maman vite d'une
famille nombreuse vite
présent pas en moins d'un an
je prends le pari dans la salle
des enfants merveilleux
à qui j'ai plus tard dédicacer mon livre
à mes enfants qui comprendront un jour
que le temps je n'ai pas passé avec eux
je les ai quand même dépensé pour eux
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui j'ai compris
mes enfants je les ailes des scènes
pendant quelques années j'ai été une de
ces familles monoparentales comme on dit
j'essaie d'abord qu'on ne choisit que
rarement de cette situation
je sers la difficulté psychologique que
ça représente d'être en même temps le
papa et la maman
j'en ai acquis la conviction que la
nation devait faire particulièrement
attention à cette situation
et puis parce qu'on n'échappe pas à son
dessein apolitique est venu me tiré par
le bras un soir de second tour
d'élection pour remplacer des orateurs
qui je prendrais pas très envie d'aller
commenter une défaite
beaucoup d'eau a coulé sous les ponts
j'ai beaucoup appris j'ai tâtonné
j'ai parfois échoué je suis tombé je me
suis toujours relevé
etc
mais
pour reprendre la lumineuse formule de
descendent mandela je n'ai jamais perdu
soit j'ai gagné soit j'ai appris
alors
alors mes amis aujourd'hui alors où
je me présente devant vous devant les
français pour la fonction suprême je
suis prête
je suis prête parce que j'ai rencontré
des milliers
des dizaines des milliers de français
j'essaie leurs souffrances leurs
attentes je sais leur désespoir mais
aussi leurs espoirs
je suis prête parce que j'ai rencontré
des chefs d'état et de gouvernement je
sais que les grandes affaires du monde
sont aussi affaire de relations
personnelles et de respect mutuel je
suis prête parce que je travaille le
projet que je vous ai présenté depuis
dix ans
ce projet gelé enrichi de toutes les
rencontres que j'ai pu faire avec des
experts des experts par seulement au
titre expertise les experts aussi au
titre expérience
mais surtout et avant tout
c'est grâce à vous que je suis prête
vous êtes ma force vous êtes con energy
vous êtes mon horizon
mes chers amis pour que par une autre
soutien je ne crois ni les trahisons ni
les embuscades ni les manoeuvres je n'ai
comme boussole que l'intérêt supérieur
de notre pays et de notre peuple la
france nous attend
la france audacieuse et impertinente la
france porte et ben libre et combative
sûre d'elle-même et généreuse la france
qu'on aime tout commence aujourd'hui
ok
[Applaudissements]
alors de lampard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
à
plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'oni tic de marine le pen un meeting
assez spécial on peut le dire on en
parlait en plateau pendant ses meetings
on a d'abord cru quelque chose de très
classique et finalement à la fin du
meeting il ya eu quelque chose qui a
changé ouais on a vraiment ces deux
parties une première partie d'un grand
classicisme on avait l'impression de
revivre les discours de 2 2010 est une
première charge très forte contre le
président là en l'occurrence emmanuel
macron accusé d'avoir créé un immense
chaos par des crises à répétition
d'avoir plongé la france qui est
polytraumatisée dans une grande
dépression puis ensuite les thèmes
classiques du rassemblement national la
sécurité l'immigration est une ouverture
sur d'autres thèmes la politique
économique la santé évidemment une
charge aussi contre contre l'europe
quelques mesures
très précises mais mais pas de pas de
financement global et puis aussi des
grandes thématiques des grands projets
et là qui sont restés relativement flou
non qu'on s'attendait à une feinte de
deux discours d'un discours vraiment
très très classique et puis il ya cette
deuxième partie est très inattendu
beaucoup plus personnelle dans laquelle
la candidate
mis en scène sa propre sa propre
expérience de façon assez surprenante
mais c'est un peu ce que faisait son
père d'une certaine manière à son à son
époque cette mise en scène et les
surprenantes d'abord parce que c'est pas
lieu de le faire dans un discours
habituellement discours s'aigrir quel
pitre est quelque chose de très codifié
et l'ajustement elle est sortie du
pupitre elle a quitté le pupitre c'est
curieux aussi parce que c'est sa
troisième candidature
qu'est ce qui la pousse à vouloir
retracer sa propre biographie alors
qu'elle est en politique depuis 20 ans
que c'est sa troisième candidature à
l'élection présidentielle
comme si elle pensait que les français
ne la connaissait pas suffisamment ou
alors comme si elle voulait donner
d'elle-même une image plus humaine on a
vraiment ce récit avec le côté tragique
de de son attentat
de l'attentât non dans sa famille a été
a été victime avec ensuite son histoire
personnelle la maternité sa famille
voilà quelque chose de très très
personnel évidemment avec beaucoup de
sincérité même si tout ça et c'était
sans doute très écrits et évidemment
préparé mais peut-être cette volonté de
se présenter aux français comme on se
retrouve son parcours dans un entretien
d'embauché et de données de d'elle-même
peut-être une image plus humaine
effectivement dans une plus est on va
voir leur albane albane boc qui est sur
place arras albane comment vous avez
vécu ce meeting au niveau de l'ambiance
commence comment il a fool maintenant on
imagine que les gens par petit à petit
oui tout à fait alors l'allocution de
marine le pen était ponctuée de
différentes cuvées ou différents
applaudissements selon la prise de
parole de marine le pen désormais les
militants quittent la salle vous le
voyez sans doute derrière moi il y à un
événement notable toutefois il ya eu 2 2
féministe vous n'avez peut-être pas vu
qu'ils ont tenté de s'introduire pendant
l'allocution de marine le pen sur la
scène elles ont vite été interpellées
dont on les a sans doute pas vu sur les
images mais l on voit là elles ont vite
été neutralisée donc les événements un
mineur cependant marine le pen ya fait
allusion dans son discours vous avez
sans doute entendu mais voilà l'incident
est clos désormais les militants
quittent la les oreilles les militants
quittent la salle après la marseillaise
qui a clôturé ce discours de marine le
pen suivant on l'a vu on va passer
peut-être les images de notre reist
charles sapin qui étaient sur place et
qui a pu filmer cette alors pas l'action
mais les mais l'arrestation des deux
semaines et qui était qui et qui était
présente sur place ça fait parti d'un de
d'un événement de de ce meeting albane
peut-être essayer de trouver un militant
pour nous dire un peu ce qu'il a pensé
de ceux de ce meeting il ya eu aussi un
autre événement alors qui ressemblait à
quelque chose d'un peu téléguidé c'est
au monde à paraître de la natalité il ya
une petite fille qui est monté avec une
fleur à la main il a offerte à marine le
pen ça sentait quand même quelque chose
de très près par et oui là c'est
clairement quelque chose
2préparer bon c'est un petit un petit
happening de communication voilà
peut-être que les médias à pression
c'est quand même une communication à
l'ancienne mais peut-être que ça peut
fonctionner et en fait ça ça change
quand même beaucoup avec la fin du
meeting comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure
une fune femmes mythiques est-ce que ça
a déjà été vu en politique ce genre de
chose de de ce livre est finalement de
montrer ses faiblesses yacé réalisé à
ses impôts ça qui s'est passé ouais
c'était c'était un peu ça il y avait il
y avait vraiment une candidate qui
cherchait à se livrer d'ailleurs
peut-être avec une grande une grande
sincérité est-ce que ça a déjà été vu
son père faisait des meetings son
pupitre avec un un micro cravate et
arpentait la scène donc il ya un peu on
est un peu dans cette dans cet état
d'esprit
dans cette filiation
mais en tout cas un meeting en deux
temps avec une première partie vraiment
très traditionnelle dans la forme voilà
un pupitre
d'un pont pter un discours très écrits
des parties
[Musique]
et puis une deuxième partie complètement
atypique imprévu inédite beaucoup plus
personnel avec à la fin le lien entre
ces deux parties puisqu'elle termine en
disant je suis prête j'ai rencontré les
français j'ai rencontré des chefs d'état
j'ai un projet qui est préparé depuis
dix ans et puis l'idée que tout commence
aujourd'hui pour reprendre ses mots ça
vraiment ces deux partis là qui d'une
certaine manière se répondent mais aussi
s'opposent ça c'est un événement de
communication un événement de politico
médiatique relativement fort et il l a
parlé quand même beaucoup de
l'expérience de cette expérience qu'elle
l'avait et en disant qu' elle avait à la
fois l'expertisé mais là aussi de
l'expérience ça fait dix ans qu'elle
mûrit son projet et ça elle veut montrer
aux français que le fait que ça fait
trois fois qu'elle ce qu'elle se
présente c'est un avantage qui joue pour
elle oui absolument montrer qu'elle
connaît le connaît la france qu'elle a
rencontré des français et que ce n'est
pas un acharnement cette troisième
candidature mais qu'au contraire c'est
un aboutissement ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est très important un
coach a beaucoup de il ya des
candidatures successifs comme ça il faut
il faut essayer de limiter au maximum
les effets d'usure de se présenter sous
un nouveau jour et de mettre en avant sa
maturité son expérience le fait qu'on
est prêt c'est exactement ce qu'elle a
fait ce soir effectivement albane on va
retourner vers vous je crois vous êtes
avec une militante du rassemblement
national est ce que vous pouvez lui
demander voilà ce qu'elle a pensé de ce
meeting si celle ci ça lui a plu
oui tout à fait je suis avec une
militante ceux qui étaient présentes
pendant tout le meeting
donc qu'est ce que vous avez pensé de
marine le pen aujourd'hui est ce qu'elle
vous a convaincu j'ai trouvé que son
discours était très réussi très
convaincant
que
très construite et argumentée
on l'a on la sent vraiment de plus en
plus prête pour cette cette fonction
présidentielle et elle donne une
impression de sérénité de deux maîtrises
quelle à travailler les dossiers comme
elle disait depuis dix ans je crois
qu'elle se prépare
toutes ces interventions sont très
réussis l'a dernièrement avec les
syndicats de policiers elle a su
comprendre leurs attentes
elle est devenue extrêmement
professionnelle vrais professionnels de
la politique
je les trouvais j'ai toujours trouvé
très compétente mais là je crois qu'elle
sait
comment dire elle a gagné en maturité en
sérénité et qu'elle est plus
convaincante que encore que qu'avant et
voila quoi c'est
c'est notre candidate et moi je suis une
simple militant pas je me suis présenté
au départemental et c'est vrai qu'on a
on a envie de la suivre à fond et de
continuer donc à à tracter sur les
marchés ou à un
tract sur les marchés coller la nuit le
matin le soir boîte et voilà c'est
quelqu'un qu'on a envie de suivre parce
qu'on a confiance en elle à l'effort
d'aller solide elle est sereine et
courageuse surtout très courageuse et
plm là elle aime la france allait me les
français est vraiment voilà c'est notre
candidate on aime vous dit qu'elle est
plus sereine est-ce que c'est pas à
double tranchant est ce que cette
sérénité qui la caractérise un peu plus
récemment
ça n'irait pas contre elle est ce que
laisse que voilà elle marine le pen
c'est sont caractérisés en étant plus
extrêmes dites-nous qu'est ce que vous
en pensez le fait qu'elles soient plus
plus sereine que ça pourrait jouer
contre elle le fait d'être peut-être par
excès de confiance oui pour pas non plus
être trop confiant dans sa fin elle
donne le sentiment qu'elle va enfin elle
veut donner le sentiment en tout cas
qu'elle va gagner je sais pas si elle
même en est convaincu personnellement
je pense que c'est plutôt positif
d'avoir ce sentiment là après
comment dire oui être en excès de
confiance n'est pas forcément non plus
très bon
[Musique]
parce que il faut avoir une vision
réaliste de la ses chances de gagner et
pas est ce que vous trouvez qu'elle ne
sait pas trop radouci
alors moi je viens de la gauche s'est
personnellement elle se serait paradou
si j'aurais jamais rejoint le
rassemblement national voilà donc moi je
viens enfin j'étais jamais été milan
militante avant dans aucun parti n'est
adhéré à aucun parti mais j'étais de
tradition familiale de gauche et j'ai
senti chez elle une fibre quand même
sociale une fibre pour la défense des
plus des plus faibles les plus fragiles
et dans son programme il ya pas mal de
mesures de gauche et c'est puisque je
les dis
merci beaucoup pour vos réponses et et
on voulait quitter tranquillement son
meeting merci beaucoup bonne soirée
et on vous je vous renvoie en direct
merci albane merci beaucoup il voit si
vous êtes encore avec un autre un autre
militant ou une autre militante pourquoi
pas pour lui demander aussi ce qu'elle a
pensé samedi temps disait que marine le
pen avait sept ce côté adoucie quand
même pendant son meeting alors elle l
avait joué ces derniers jours ce côté un
peu adouci face à eric zemmour et
pendant son meeting on a quand même
senti que ont réutilisé aurait utilisé
les anciennes méthodes on va dire oui
alors il ya une première partie du
discours en tout cas on était vraiment
sur les fondamentaux y compris dans la
forme du rassemblement national quand
elle dénonçait synthèse terrible du
cynisme et de l'injustice pour désigner
définir la politique du chef de l'état
elle parle à un moment des talibans de
la verdure je cite quand elle propose
des expulsés manu militari les
clandestins bon ni sur la forme ni sur
le fond on est vraiment on peut pas dire
la queue on est sur un discours qu'ils
soient qu'ils soient adoucie
je crois que c'est aussi le sens du
meeting faut parler quand même à sa base
électorale aux personnes qui sont qui
sont dans la salle quand on fait des
interviews en direction d'un public plus
large on peut se permettre d'avoir un
discours un peu plus été un petit peu
plus nuancé moi j'étais frappé aussi de
voir que dans son discours il y avait
énormément de dépenses
qui finalement n'était pas budgétée les
les recettes et
ils sont pour l'instant pas vraiment
documenté donc peut-être que appareils
de fraude sociale de oui mais c'est pas
la valeur de l'ensemble des dépenses
qu'on était en fait c'est un catalogue
de dépenses 1 essentiellement
plus de fonctionnaires augmenter la
mesure forte c'est la baisse de la tva à
5% de la tva
certains comme les milliards d'aidé des
mesures en direction des tpe le soutient
la suppression de l'impôt sur le revenu
pour les pour les moins de 30 ans etc
etc mais en face on n'a pas vraiment de
financement pour toutes ces mesures il
ya quelques éléments qui ont été évoqués
mais vraiment en passant
donc voilà un discours c'est pas
l'exposé détaillé chiffres et d'un
programme mais il va falloir que ça
vienne justement pour crédibiliser cette
prise de parole autour de l'expérience
et d'un projet construit pendant dix ans
il ya eu encore une fois une cible
pendant ce discours c'est macron est pas
et mourront zemmour n'en a pas parlé on
a compris qu'elle est ce qu'elle
laquelle on a parlé quand il a parlé de
des handicapés forcément en situation de
handicap parce que pour pour pour un peu
lui répondre sur cette question là c'est
important aussi pour elle de jouer sur
ce tableau la wii le nom d'eric zemmour
n'a jamais été cité celui de valérie
pécresse l'a été à deux reprises
notamment pour la présenter comme un
clown d'emmanuel macron et pour moquer
une de ces mesures mais c'est
essentiellement le chef de l'état qui a
concentré toutes les flèches de la
candidate du rassemblement national
parce qu'elle veut ré instaurer ce match
et tenter de prendre sa revanche sur la
fiche perdu du deuxième tour 2010 est il
effectivement qui avait laissé une trace
en rappel sinon beaucoup de questions
toujours dessus assure international
sortir de l'otan sayanim bien beaucoup
de choses qu'on savait déjà et qui sont
pas vraiment très nouvelle chez marine
le pen oui alors là on retrouve vraiment
les éléments très classique
l'armée nationale
évidemment tout une charge contre contre
bruxelles
voilà on retrouve aussi les grands
fondamentaux l'idée c'est quand même de
à nouveau dans dans dans le prolongement
de ce qui vient d'être dit de
réinstaurer ce clivage entre les
mondialistes à dire le camp d' emmanuel
macron et puis de l'autre côté les
patriotes qu'elle qu'elle veut avec elle
veut incarner on à jean-michel marx dans
les commentaires qui nous dit la
stratégie du rn depuis quelques années
s'est socialisée de discours pour
récupérer les anciens ouvriers est ce
que on le voit est ce que on est ce que
ça marche de plus en plus oui il ya eu
des il ya eu d
ou des points dans ce discours il ya
tout notamment tout le volet qui a été
consacrée à la santé pour à l'incitation
à l'installation des jeunes mais des
jeunes médecins dans les zones rurales
tout l'aspect sociétal vous en avez
parlé sur la revalorisation de l'aide de
l'allocation adulte handicapé sur la
question des des aidants par exemple ça
ce sont des thématiques nouvelles et un
discours du rassemblement national et
être
directe encore un peu de deux pastis il
n'est pas habitué
vous pouvez revenir sur ce que vous
disiez non je disais que tout est toutes
ces thématiques qui apparaissent depuis
depuis quelques années dans la dans le
discours du front national sont
évidemment destinée à élargir son
électorat effectivement pour assez pour
réussir apparemment cette base est ce
que ce côté qu'on l'a vu à la fin du à
la fin du meeting une fois de plus ce
côté un peu je me livre est ce que c'est
pour se différencier d'eric zemmour qui
avait peut-être une une vivent plutôt
austère on peut on le voit de façon plus
austère
oui ça participe d'une forme de
spectacularisation aussi de la vie
politique l'élection présidentielle
c'est la rencontre d'une personnalité
avec le peuple et donc il faut aussi que
cette personnalité ce livre on sait
qu'il ya des candidats qui sont petit
peu plus verrouillés et que l'électorat
du mal à bien identifier
à qui il a à faire ça pue pénalisé par
exemple lionel jospin en 95 vous
souvenez de sa formule fendre l'armure
c'était ça ce qu'il voulait dire c'est à
dire se départir d'une forme de pudeur
pour donner à voir ce qu'il était
vraiment et pour que les lecteurs
puissent faire son choix en toute
connaissance de cause marine le pen l'a
rappelé un on a besoin quand on est
électeur de connaître la personnalité de
la personne à qui on va confier la plus
haute charge de la république
effectivement merci beaucoup frédéric
micheau d'avoir été avec moi pendant
cependant ce live
alors peut-être que albane avoir un
dernier militant sur place je ne sais
pas encore mais en tout cas merci en
tout cas fait des commissions d'avoir
été avec moi votre livre le sacre de
l'opinion qui est disponible c'est chez
les éditions du cerf c'est très
intéressant je me pensais et je crois
qu'on n'aura pas le dernier militant
mais c'est pas grave bercy en tout cas
d'avoir été très nombreux à six il est
prêt on me dit dans l'oreillette ce qui
est des voix albane vous avez la parole
si vous voulez parler qu'est ce qu'on a
pensé ce militant de ce meeting
j'ai je suis avec nathan qui fait partie
des jeunes avec marine et qui est venu
de toulouse qui avez vous pensé
maintenant de ce meeting très très beau
meeting
enthousiasmant
vers l'avenir j'ai trouvé marine superbe
durant ce meeting est vraiment jeu bravo
l es ce que vous avez trouvé qu'elle
sait renouveler au contraire c'est
toujours toujours la même donc on
retrouve fur et à mesure de ses meetings
alors oui c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
je les rejoins parce que je trouve que
sur l'argumentation sur son programme
qui est vraiment structuré bâti et c'est
pour ça que je les rejoins il ya très il
ya très peu d'ailleurs je trouve qu'il
ya une vraie une nette évolution depuis
2010 cette voie là est ce que vous
avancez capable de rivaliser avec eric
zemmour aux autres candidats de la
droite nationaliste pour moi eric
zemmour n'est pas pour moi le vrai rival
c'est emmanuel macron aujourd'hui réglé
mansanné cas il est à 12 % dans les
sondages pour moi c'est emmanuel macron
et valérie pécresse au genre de jeu il
est vrai danger pour la france je pense
merci beaucoup d'attention pour vos
réponses vous voulez ça va coûter ce
meeting un soir je l'espère reprendre la
main merci
merci d'avoir été avec nous depuis reims
avec daphné caravaca merci nouvelle fois
frédéric micheau d'avoir été avec moi
pendant tout ce direct merci à julien
tunnel et s'il marche à t'inquiéter en
régie pendant ce live il vous dit à
bientôt pour de nouveaux directs sur
figaro la ddt